I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hello. Hi there.
我是珍娜·菲舍尔，我是安吉拉·金西。我们曾一起出演过《办公室》，并且是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了终极《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。女士们，我们就是《办公室》。大家好。嗨。
Today we're going to talk about garage sale. We are. And you know what? I have to say, it kind of feels like we're sitting in a garage sale. It really does. We need to share for a minute, I think, that we are recording on the very last day that Ear Wolf has its studio. As we sit here, there are folks moving tables out.
今天我们要聊的是“车库大甩卖”。是的。你知道吗？我得说，感觉我们就像坐在一个车库大甩卖的现场一样。真的太像了。我想我们得花一分钟时间分享一下，我们现在正在Ear Wolf录音室的最后一天进行录音。当我们坐在这里时，有人正在把桌子搬出去。
There's a whole area where there's just misplaced cups and coffee mugs and different things. And it's like, there's a little sign, take if you want it. Yeah. They're being packed up. I just boxed up my desk. My desk that I was so excited to get just a few months ago. I know. They're taking pictures off the walls.
整个区域到处都是放错地方的杯子、咖啡马克杯和各种东西。就像有个小牌子上面写着：喜欢就拿去吧。是的。它们正在被打包。我刚刚把我的办公桌装箱了。几个月前我得到它时可是兴奋得不得了。我知道。他们正在把墙上的画取下来。
It kind of feels like we're sitting in a rummage sale. And I'm a little sad, I have to say, to say goodbye to this place where we created the podcast and we had so many wonderful memories in this little studio. And truth be told, we don't even know where we're recording next week. But that's what we're doing this afternoon. We're going to try to find a new place to record and the show will go on. And thankfully, me and Jenna and Cassie and Sam, we're all in it together. We will find a place, even if it's just a nice, you know, hang out in one of our garages.
感觉我们就像坐在一个旧货跳蚤市场里。我必须说，要向这个我们创作了播客、在这个小录音室里留下那么多美好回忆的地方告别，我感到有些难过。说实话，我们甚至不知道下周要在哪里录制。但这就是我们今天下午要做的事情。我们要试着找一个新地方录音，节目会继续进行。值得庆幸的是，我和珍娜、卡茜、萨姆，我们都在一起。我们会找到一个地方，哪怕只是舒舒服服地待在我们其中一个人的车库里。
But we're a little sad today, sad, mad, sad, sad, mad, sad, mad, sad, mad. Yeah. Jenna does not like change, you guys. No. It makes you sad, mad. It makes you sad, mad. All right. But this is a wonderful episode.
但我们今天有点难过，难过、生气、难过、难过、生气、难过、生气、难过、生气。是的。大家注意啦，珍娜不喜欢改变。没有。这让你又难过又生气。这让你又难过又生气。好吧。但这是一集精彩的剧集。
I just wanted to share with you guys, though, what's going on around us as we record garage sale. We're sort of sitting in a garage sale. Well, this episode was season seven, episode 19. It was written by John Vidi and directed by Steve Carell. I was so tickled to discover that he directed this episode that included such a momentous moment for his character. Yeah.
不过，我只是想和大家分享一下我们在录制“车库大甩卖”时周围发生了什么。我们有点像坐在车库大甩卖的现场。嗯，这一集是第七季第十九集。由约翰·维蒂编剧，史蒂夫·卡瑞尔执导。我非常高兴地发现，他执导了这集包含了他所饰演角色的如此重大时刻的剧集。是的。
Wow. I had forgotten that. Me too. And then when I saw it, I was like, oh, then I had all these memories, you know? And he took such care with all of those scenes. We'll get to them. Well, here is your summary. In this episode, Dunder Mifflin is throwing a garage sale in the warehouse.
哇。我都忘得精光了。我也是。然后当我看到它的时候，我想，哦，接着我就有了所有这些回忆，你知道吗？他对所有这些场景都倾注了极大的关爱。我们一会儿就会讲到。好吧，下面是你的剧情梗概。在这一集中，邓德米夫林公司正在仓库里举办一场车库大甩卖。
Dwight tries to trade his way to the best item in the garage sale, but gets bested by Jim. Meanwhile, Michael plans to propose to Holly. However, she might need to move to Colorado to take care of her aging parents. So let's get into fast fact number one. This was Amy Ryan's last episode of The Office. This was it, her last appearance. And here's a fun tidbit.
德怀特试图通过以物换物，在车库大甩卖中换到最好的物品，但却被吉姆给比了下去。与此同时，迈克尔计划向霍莉求婚。然而，她可能需要搬到科罗拉多去照顾年迈的父母。那么让我们进入第一条快讯。这是艾米·瑞安在《办公室》里的最后一集。就是这样，她最后一次出场。这里有一个有趣的趣事。
Holly's first episode that she appears in and her last episode both contain proposals. There's Andy and Angela in her first episode, which was Goodbye, Toby. And now Holly and Michael in this one. Oh, that's such a great detail. I know. Amy did an interview with Fulcher and she said this about the episode, quote, the script was so sweet that it made us all have a good cry, coupled with the fact that it was the start of Steve's departure and it was my own, yeah, there wasn't a dry eye in the house.
霍莉出场的第一集和最后一集都包含了求婚情节。在她第一集《告别托比》里有安迪和安吉拉，而这一集里则是霍莉和迈克尔。哦，这个细节太棒了。我知道。艾米接受了福尔彻的采访，她关于这一集是这样说的，引述：“剧本太甜了，让我们所有人都痛痛快快地哭了一场，再加上这是史蒂夫离开的开始，这也是我自己的离去，是的，全场没有一个人眼眶是干的。”
And that was so true. So true. And boy, when I watched this episode, Angela, I sobbed. It came over me. I wasn't even expecting it. Same. I went back and I read the shooting draft. You guys should know, usually when I go back and look at the shooting draft, there's also
这话太对了。太对了。天哪，当我看到这一集时，安吉拉，我泣不成声。那种情绪涌上心头。我甚至毫无心理准备。我也是。我回去读了拍摄剧本。大家应该知道，通常当我回去看拍摄剧本时，还会看到
the table draft and there's maybe one or two little rewrites and tweaks. And then we get to the shooting draft, right? This episode was pretty much exactly as it was at the table read. Wow. Yeah. And there's barely any candy bag alts at all. There was like one for Pam. That was it.
围读剧本，而且可能有一两个小的重写和微调。然后我们才拿到拍摄剧本，对吧？这一集几乎完全就是围读剧本时的样子。哇。是的。而且几乎没有任何糖果袋替代台词。只有帕姆的一句。就这样。
It is as it was written. It is so beautifully written. I cried reading the shooting draft. Angela, do you remember the AV club writer, Miles McNutt, who we talked about last week? Yes. How he did not care for Todd Packer? No, Miles was not a fan. Well, he gave this episode an A minus.
它就是按原样写出来的。写得太美妙了。我读拍摄剧本时都哭了。安吉拉，你还记得我们上周聊过的AV俱乐部作家迈尔斯·麦克纳特吗？记得。他怎么就那么不喜欢托德·帕克呢？没错，迈尔斯可不是他的粉丝。好吧，他给这一集打了个A减。
Hey. And he called it a quote, spiritual successor to Casino Night. So Miles really liked this one. Yeah. And so this episode was voted the 20th best overall episode of the entire series by Office Tally fans. And I mean, we made 201 episodes and this was number 20. This was a very well liked episode is what I'm getting at.
嘿。他称之为“《赌场之夜》的精神继任者”。所以迈尔斯真的很喜欢这一集。是的。并且这一集被Office Tally粉丝投票选为全剧总共第20佳剧集。我的意思是，我们制作了201集，而这是第20名。我想说的是，这是一集非常受欢迎的剧集。
Now, fast fact number two, you know, at the end of this episode, Michael announces that he's moving to Colorado with Holly while following the airing of this episode, the governor of Colorado, John Hickenlooper, issued a press release appointing Michael Scott to the position of director of paper distribution in the Department of Natural Resources for Colorado. He said, quote, Scott's success in selling paper will help Colorado effectively and efficiently move the large amount of bark beetle lumber from the forest and into the marketplace, creating tons of jobs and making lots of money. He also said, quote, this is a unique opportunity to resolve Colorado's forest health and budget
现在是第二条快讯，你知道的，在本集的结尾，迈克尔宣布他要和霍莉一起搬到科罗拉多去，而随着这一集的播出，科罗拉多州州长约翰·希肯卢珀发表了一份新闻稿，任命迈克尔·斯科特担任科罗拉多州自然资源部纸张分销总监一职。他说，引述：“斯科特在销售纸张方面的成功将帮助科罗拉多州高效且有效地将森林中大量的树皮甲虫木材运送到市场上，从而创造大量的就业机会并赚取巨额利润。”他还说，引述：“这是一个解决科罗拉多州森林健康和预算
issues. We've hired Michael based on his skills, personal drive and love for that's what she said jokes. Now how many people that heard that thought maybe there was someone named Michael Scott that was hired and not a television character? I know it's so true. Like I feel like my grandmother might have been like, oh, yeah, we just got Michael Scott. He's going to help with the with the paper.
问题的独特机会。我们根据迈克尔的技能、个人进取心以及对‘这就是她说的’笑话的热爱聘用了他。”现在有多少人听到这个消息时，以为真的是一个叫迈克尔·斯科特的人被雇佣了，而不是一个电视剧角色呢？我知道，真的太像了。我觉得我奶奶可能会觉得，哦，对，我们刚招了迈克尔·斯科特。他要去帮忙处理纸张的事。
And then, you know, a year later, they're like, what happened with that guy is doing nothing. Well, I heard he liked dirty jokes. Exactly. All right, that brings me to fast fact number three. Maybe one of my favorite fast facts ever, because in this episode Dwight trades his way from a thumbtack to a pouch of magic beans, well to a telescope, but then some legumes. Yes.
然后，你知道，一年后，他们会说，那家伙到底怎么回事，什么也没做。嗯，我听说他喜欢荤段子。一点没错。好吧，这让我想到了第三条快讯。这可能是我最喜欢的快讯之一，因为在本集中，德怀特用一个图钉一路物物交换，最后换到了一袋魔豆，好吧，其实是望远镜，但后来换成了豆子。是的。
This storyline was based on a true story known to many people as the story of the red paper clip. Back in July of 2005, a Canadian blogger named Kyle McDonald started with a red paper clip that he found on his desk and he traded his way to a house. He blogged about his journey and it became this really famous story. And he even did a TED talk about it. And here's a clip where he explains how it all began. 10 years ago, I was looking down on my desk and I saw a red paper clip sitting there and
这个故事情节取材于一个真实的故事，许多人称之为“红色回形针”的故事。早在2005年7月，一个名叫凯尔·麦克唐纳的加拿大博客作者从他在桌上找到的一个红色回形针开始，通过不断物物交换，最终换到了一栋房子。他在博客上记录了自己的这段经历，这个故事变得非常著名。他甚至还为此做了一场TED演讲。这里有一个他解释这一切是如何开始的片段。10年前，我低头看着我的桌子，看到一个红色回形针放在那儿，然后
I said, you know what, I remember this game called bigger and better where you start with something small and you trade it for something bigger. And then you repeat. I wonder what would happen if I took this red paper clip and tried to trade it. So I posted a picture of that red paper clip on a website called Craigslist and two girls named Ronnie and Karina responded and said, hey, that's pretty cool. We'd like to trade with you. We've got a pen shaped like a fish.
我说，你知道吗，我记得有个游戏叫“越换越大”，就是从一个小东西开始，把它换成更大的东西。然后重复这个过程。我想，如果我拿着这个红色回形针试着去交换，会发生什么呢？于是我把那个红色回形针的照片发布在一个叫Craigslist的网站上，两个名叫罗妮和卡丽娜的女孩回复了我，说，嘿，这挺酷的。我们想跟你换。我们有一支鱼形笔。
I was really excited. This was a cool pen. This was bigger and better than a red paper clip. How far can I go with this idea? Anybody want a fish, a pen shaped like a fish? Absolutely. My name's Annie and I've got a doorknob with a crazy face on it. Two trades in, I've already gone way up from a paper clip and I was thinking like, how
我真的超级兴奋。这真是一支酷笔。这可比一个红色回形针更大更好。我带着这个想法能走多远呢？有人想要一条鱼吗，一支鱼形笔？绝对想。我叫安妮，我有一个上面有疯狂表情的门把手。才交换了两次，就已经比回形针升级太多了，我当时就在想，我究竟
far can I go with this? How far can I keep going until like one day owned a house or something from this? So he did. He kept making trades until he got a house. It is such a great Ted talk. If you guys haven't seen it, we'll put a link to it in our stories, but it's amazing. It really is. And something that's fun is that with each of the 14 trades, that's how many it took.
能走多远呢？我能一直换下去，直到有一天能用这个换到一栋房子什么的吗？于是他真的这么做了。他一直不断地交换，直到换到了一栋房子。这是一场多么精彩的TED演讲啊。如果你们还没看过的，我们会在动态里放一个链接，但这真的太棒了。确实如此。有趣的是，这总共经历了14次交换，每一次交换他都有
He has a picture of himself with each of the people that he traded with. So here's what happened. He found someone who traded him a camping stove for that crazy doorknob. For the camping stove, he got a Honda generator. He traded the generator for an instant party, which was basically an empty beer keg with a promise to fill it up and a neon Budweiser sign. The instant party got the attention of a radio personality who traded him his worst snowmobile. Oh yeah.
一张自己与交换对象合影的照片。事情是这样的：他找到了一个人，用那个疯狂的门把手换到了一个野营炉。用这个野营炉，他换到了一台本田发电机。他用发电机换了一个“即兴派对”，基本上就是一个空啤酒桶，承诺会把它灌满，外加一个百威霓虹灯招牌。这个“即兴派对”引起了一位电台名人的注意，对方用自己最破的雪地摩托跟他换了。哦，对。
Which was really funny because I guess like I had a lot of snowmobiles. He gave them this crappy one. I'll give you my worst one for this instant party. He traded the snowmobile for a two-person trip to the Rockies in British Columbia. He traded the trip for a box truck. He traded the box truck for a recording contract. Then, he found a woman who had a duplex and only half of it was rented. And this woman was like, I will give you one year free rent in my unrented side of my duplex.
这真的太搞笑了，因为我猜他大概有很多雪地摩托。他给了他们这辆破烂的。我把最破的这辆给你来换这个“即兴派对”。他用雪地摩托换了一次不列颠哥伦比亚省落基山脉的双人游。他用这次旅行换了一辆厢式货车。他用厢式货车换到了一份唱片合约。然后，他找到了一个有一栋复式公寓且只租出了一半的女人。这个女人说，我把我的复式公寓里没有出租的那一半免费租给你一年。
For that recording contract. And he was like, great. So when the renter of the other side of the duplex found out, she was like, I would like a year of free rent in the duplex I'm already living in. What if I traded you an afternoon with my boss? And Kyle was like, who's your boss? Well, it turns out that her boss was Alice Cooper. And Kyle explained that Alice Cooper's tour manager called him and said, why don't you
来换取那份唱片合约。而他觉得，太棒了。于是，当复式公寓另一边的租客发现后，她说，我也想在我已经住着的复式公寓里免费住一年。如果我用一个下午和你老板相处的时间来跟你换呢？凯尔就问了，谁是你的老板？结果证明，她的老板竟然是艾利斯·库珀。凯尔解释说，艾利斯·库珀的巡演经理打电话给他，说，你为什么不
come on down, see what an afternoon with Alice Cooper is like, and then you'll know what you're trading. We'll offer one for a trade. And the video in the TED Talk is so cool because you see him on stage with Alice Cooper and Alice Cooper brings out a giant red paper clip. Yeah, he's so into it. It's so cool. So now here's the crazy part.
过来看看，体验一下和艾利斯·库珀度过一个下午是什么感觉，这样你就知道你在交换什么了。我们可以提供这个作为交换。TED演讲里的视频太酷了，因为你可以看到他和艾利斯·库珀同台，而艾利斯·库珀拿出一个巨大的红色回形针。是的，他太投入了。太酷了。现在，最疯狂的部分来了。
This is where it got a little bit like, why? Yeah. He trades the afternoon with Alice Cooper for a kiss snow globe. Yes. But he had done some research. Yes. He was able to trade the snow globe for a role in a movie. And here's how.
这就是事情变得有点像“为什么会这样？”的地方。是的。他用和艾利斯·库珀相处的一个下午换到了一个KISS乐队的水晶球。对的。但他做了一些研究。没错。他成功用这个水晶球换到了一个电影角色。具体是这样的：
And this was the only time during the entire project where I had another trade lined up. Every other trade had come along serendipitously, and it had just been this amazing experience. However, two months previous to all this, this guy had called me up and said, hey, my name's Corbin Bernsen. I'm a huge Hollywood actor. I'm making a movie, and I would like to offer a paid speaking credited role in a Hollywood film. Would you be interested in trading for that?
这也是整个项目中唯一一次我提前物色好下一次交换的时候。其他的每一次交换都是机缘巧合，而且都是一次奇妙的经历。然而，在此之前两个月，这个人打电话给我说，嘿，我叫科尔宾·伯恩森。我是个好莱坞大演员。我在拍一部电影，我想提供一个好莱坞电影里有台词且署名的付费角色。你对此有兴趣交换吗？
I had just done the recording contract trade, and I was like, yes, absolutely. This sounds perfect. He hung up the phone, and I'm like, Corbin Bernsen, who is this guy? Turns out he is very well known. He's been in many major movies, and he also, according to Wikipedia, has the world's largest snow globe collection, over 6,500 snow globes. Since it was Wikipedia, I knew it was true, and I just sort of kept it in the back of my head.
我刚刚完成了唱片合约的交换，当时我就想，太好了，当然有。这听起来太完美了。他挂了电话，我在想，科尔宾·伯恩森，这家伙是谁？原来他非常知名。他出演过许多重磅电影，而且根据维基百科的记载，他拥有世界上最大的水晶球收藏，超过6500个水晶球。既然是维基百科，我知道这肯定是真的，于是我就把这件事默默记在了脑子里。
And when Mark said he had a kiss snow globe, I was like, oh, this is perfect. Called Corbin Corbin. Do you want the kiss snow globe? He's like, send me a picture. I sent him a picture. Corbin called back. Not only do I want it, I need it. So yeah, he kind of knew if he could get his hands on a snow globe, he'd be able to trade
当马克说他有一个KISS乐队的水晶球时，我就想，哦，这太完美了。我给科尔宾打了电话。你想要KISS乐队的水晶球吗？他说，发张照片给我。我发了张照片给他。科尔宾回电话了。我不仅想要，我简直太需要了。所以，是的，他其实心里清楚，只要能弄到一个水晶球，他就能
it for this movie role. A really unique snow globe. Yes, exactly. So now he's got this role in a movie, and here's how he trades that for a house. Following this, the economic development officer of the town of Kipling, Saskatchewan, a fellow named Bert Roach, called me up and said, we see that you've been doing this project. Our town has a couple extra houses that we own. Would there be a potential that maybe we could trade one of these houses for something you
用它换来这个电影角色。一个非常独特的水晶球。对，一点没错。所以现在他得到了一个电影角色，他是这样用它换到一套房子的：在此之后，萨斯喀彻温省吉普林镇的经济发展官，一个叫伯特·罗奇的家伙打电话给我说，我们看到你一直在做这个项目。我们镇上有几套多出来的属于我们自己的房子。有没有可能，我们用其中一套房子来跟你手头的某样东西交换呢？
have? And I said, well, right now I have a role in the movie. He's like, oh, that'd be perfect. What we were thinking is having a huge housewarming party, a huge celebration, inviting everyone in the world to come to Kipling, and we could offer an opportunity. We'll call it Kipling Idol, and we'll have live auditions for the movie role here, right in town. And I said, that's absolutely perfect, Bert.
我说，嗯，现在我有一个电影角色。他说，哦，那太完美了。我们想的是举办一场盛大的乔迁派对，一场盛大的庆祝活动，邀请全世界的人都来吉普林，我们可以提供一个机会。我们称之为“吉普林偶像”，然后在这里，就在我们镇上，为这个电影角色进行现场试镜。我说，这绝对完美，伯特。
What do you need to do to make this happen? He's like, well, we need town council approval. And I said, all right, well, if you can get it, that'd be great. He called me back two weeks later, and he's like, I did it. I got town council approval. We can make the trade. Turns out town council approval is getting two people to put their hand in the air. But full credit to Bert, he made it happen.
你需要做些什么才能让这成为现实？他说，嗯，我们需要镇议会的批准。我说，好吧，如果你能搞定，那就太好了。两周后他给我回电话说，我做到了。我拿到了镇议会批准。我们可以进行交易了。原来镇议会的批准就是让两个人把手举起来。不过必须高度赞扬伯特，他真的做成了。
And we traveled to Kipling, and there we are. That's how you trade a paperclip for a house. So Kyle actually moved into the house. This is the part I was curious about because I watched the Ted Talk, but I was like, so what happened after? He moved to the town of Kipling. He lived in the house. They put a giant red paperclip on the front lawn, and after a few years of living there,
然后我们去了吉普林，这就是我们当时的样子。这就是你如何用一个回形针换到一套房子。所以凯尔真的搬进了那栋房子。这就是我最好奇的部分，因为我看了TED演讲，但我当时在想，那后来怎么样了？他搬到了吉普林镇。他住在那栋房子里。他们在前草坪上竖了一个巨大的红色回形针，在里面住了几年之后，
he decided to give the house back to the town, and the town turned it into a cafe and a tourist attraction. Aw. Yeah. He thought at first he would trade the house for something, but then he thought about it, and he thought, no, I think the house had already become kind of a tourist attraction. In fact, in the listing for the house trade, he said, please know this house is a tourist attraction.
他决定把房子还给小镇，小镇把它变成了一家咖啡馆和一个旅游景点。哇。是的。他一开始想过要把这栋房子再换点什么，但后来他琢磨了一下，心想，不，我觉得这栋房子本身就已经成了一个旅游景点。事实上，在出售这栋房子的房源信息里，他说，请注意，这栋房子是一个旅游景点。
People will be driving by this house all the time, taking pictures with it, and there's a giant red paperclip in the front lawn that you can't move. But in the end, he decided to just return the house back to the town, and it's a really cool thing for this town that they have this story. Well, I really enjoyed that story. I loved watching the Ted Talk, and then the piece of it that he spoke about, about the human connection along the way. Yes, me too.
人们会经常开车经过这栋房子，跟它拍照，而且前草坪上有一个巨大的红色回形针是挪不走的。但最终，他决定把房子还给小镇，对这个小镇来说，拥有这样一个故事真的是一件非常酷的事情。嗯，我真的很喜欢这个故事。我特别喜欢看那个TED演讲，还有他谈到的关于一路上人与人之间的连接的那一部分。是的，我也是。
Here is a clip of how Kyle summed up the experience. The best part about this whole project, though, is fun making the trades for things. It's easier to tell the story with the objects, but it was the people behind it saying, yes, let's build something. Let's do something together. Let's collaborate. Let's see what happens. That was what one of our paperclip was all about.
这里有一个剪辑，是关于凯尔如何总结这段经历的。不过，整个项目最棒的部分其实并不在于通过交换东西获得乐趣。用物品来讲述故事虽然很容易，但真正重要的是背后的那些人，他们说：好，让我们一起来创造点什么。让我们一起做点事情。让我们合作。让我们看看会发生什么。这就是我们的回形针的故事所传达的一切。
If I hadn't traded away that red paperclip, I'd just be a guy sitting there at his desk holding a paperclip in his hand, wondering what would happen if I did something with the paperclip. If you have a paperclip, trade it away. You might only get a fish pan, but it might be the single step that leads to an amazing journey. Yes, that's what I was talking about. I love the whole journey.
如果我没有把那个红色回形针换出去，我可能就只是一个坐在桌子前、手里拿着个回形针、琢磨着用它做点什么会有什么结果的普通人。如果你有一个回形针，把它换出去吧。你可能最后只能换到一支鱼形笔，但这或许就是通往一段精彩旅程的第一步。没错，这就是我一直在说的。我喜欢整个旅程。
Well, lady, that's all I got. Should we take a break and then we'll be back to Breakdown Garage soon? Yeah, because I have a table by table breakdown of what all the Dunder Mifflin crew is trying to sell. We'll be right back. We are back and there is a garage sale underway in the warehouse. Everyone is setting up. There is a great aerial view of the warehouse as if the camera operator was up at the little
好吧，女士们，我这就这些了。我们要不要休息一下，然后马上回来继续剖析“车库大甩卖”？好啊，因为我有一份逐个摊位的清单，上面列了邓德米夫林员工们都在试着卖些什么。我们马上回来。我们回来了，仓库里的车库大甩卖正在火热进行中。每个人都在摆摊。仓库的鸟瞰镜头太棒了，就好像摄像师站在那些假楼梯的最顶端
top of the fakie stairs looking down. At 0.2 seconds, you can really get a great view of the room. I'm sure you caught this too, Jenna, but even in this wide aerial view, I could see Michael's broken plasma TV. Yes. We'll see a close-up of it later. Everyone has such great stuff at their tables. When we get to each person's table, Jenna, we'll share about what's on those tables.
俯视下方一样。在0.2秒的时候，你真的可以把整个房间尽收眼底。我确信你也注意到了，珍娜，甚至在这个广角的鸟瞰镜头里，我也能看到迈克尔那台摔碎的等离子电视。是的。我们稍后会看到它的特写。每个人的摊位上都有好东西。当我们走到每个人的摊位时，珍娜，我们会分享这些摊位上都有什么。
Well, Randy said there was a lot of licensing and legal clearance issues on this episode because of all the products shown. I bet. This all fell on our production coordinator, the wonderful Meg Shave, and it starts right away when Pam notices those Will and Grace DVDs on Oscars' table. Phil Shea purchased an actual Will and Grace DVD and NBC gave us clearance, but you might note that it is in a group of other DVDs, and per Meg, we were allowed to verbally mention the pile of CDs as long as we did not show a close-up of the DVD cover.
兰迪说，由于展示了各种产品，这一集有很多版权和法律清关方面的问题。我敢说肯定是这样。这一切都落在了我们的制作统筹、了不起的梅格·谢夫身上，而且从帕姆注意到奥斯卡摊位上的《威尔和格蕾丝》DVD开始，这个问题就立刻出现了。菲尔·谢伊买了一张真正的《威尔和格蕾丝》DVD，全国广播公司（NBC）也批准了我们使用，但你可能会注意到它和其他DVD混在一起。据梅格所说，只要我们不给DVD封面特写，我们是允许口头提及这堆CD的。
This was the rules. The rules for this table, and each table had different rules. The other items on Oscars' table were an umbrella, an old side-by-side DVD VHS player. Remember those? Yes. Oh my gosh, that's old tech. That's old tech. A rainbow kite, a fake lobster, some autumn fake flower arrangements and baskets, and
这就是规则。这个摊位的规则，而且每个摊位都有不同的规则。奥斯卡摊位上的其他物品还有一把雨伞、一台旧的DVD/VHS一体机。还记得那些吗？记得。哦天哪，那是老科技了。那是老科技了。一块彩虹风筝、一只假龙虾、一些秋季假花艺装饰和篮子，还有
did anyone else catch the set of owl figurines? I did not. He's got lots of owl chotchkeys. Now of the things on Oscars' table, which thing would you have bought, Angela, because I know immediately what I would have wanted. I mean, I probably would have snagged one of those owl figurines. They're kind of amazing. I didn't see them closely, so that could be the case.
有没有人注意到那套猫头鹰小雕像？我没有。他有很多猫头鹰小摆件。在奥斯卡摊位上的这些东西里，你会买哪个，安吉拉，因为我知道我一眼就会想要什么。嗯，我大概会顺走其中一个猫头鹰小雕像。它们简直绝了。我没有仔细看，所以也有可能是那样。
But what I would like is one of those fake autumn flower arrangements, please. You would. You would. You do love a fake flower arrangement. I just cleared a fake autumn flower arrangement off of our desks that you brought in from home. Yes. Pam is going to have a talking head that sort of explains what's happening here.
但我想要的是那些秋季假花艺装饰中的一个，谢谢。你肯定会。你就会。你确实很喜欢假花艺装饰。我刚从我们的桌子上清理掉一个你从家里拿来的秋季假花艺装饰。是的。帕姆接下来会有一段面对镜头的独白，用来解释这里正在发生的事情。
She says Dundramiflin is having their very first garage sale. Like many Americans, we realize we have a lot of things that we really didn't need, and 10 cents of every dollar is going into the party fund so they can throw parties for themselves. All right. I'm going to have a question coming up, because Dwight opens the doors to the warehouse, and when he does that, there is a sign revealed. Yes.
她说邓德米夫林正在举办他们的第一场车库大甩卖。和许多美国人一样，我们意识到我们有很多其实根本不需要的东西，而每一美元中的10美分将存入派对基金，这样他们就可以为自己举办派对。好吧。我马上要问一个问题，因为德怀特打开了通往仓库的大门，当他这么做时，一块牌子露了出来。是的。
Here's what the sign says. Dundramiflin employees charity garage sale today only, 9 a.m. to 4 p.m. no early bird. Charity. Charity. What's the charity? The party fund? Exactly. I was like, whoa, whoa, whoa.
牌子上是这么写的：邓德米夫林员工慈善车库大甩卖，仅限今天，上午9点到下午4点，谢绝早到。慈善。慈善。什么慈善？派对基金？没错。当时我就想，哇，哇，哇。
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa. Maybe Pam is more corrupt than we thought. Oh my gosh, you might be right, Angela. We had a fan question from Nicole W. in Boise, Maryland. Are they having a yard sale in the warehouse during a work day? If so, that means not only are there no sales being made, but also the warehouse can't fulfill any deliveries because they can't get any products in or out of the warehouse. These are very good points.
哇，哇，哇，哇。也许帕姆比我们想象的还要腐败呢。哦天哪，安吉拉，你可能说得对。我们收到了来自马里兰州博伊西的妮可·W.的粉丝提问。他们在工作日期间在仓库里办庭院大甩卖吗？如果是这样的话，这意味着不仅没有任何销售额进账，而且仓库也无法完成任何发货，因为他们根本没法把任何产品运进或运出仓库。这些是非常好的观点。
I know. It didn't occur to me till I read the fan question that we're completely blocking off the giant door for delivery trucks. No work is being done on this day, and I do think it's a work day because everyone is dressed for work. You're not in your casual Saturday, I'm going to a garage sale close. No. Dwight's going to start by walking over to Meredith's table.
我知道。直到我读到这个粉丝提问我才意识到，我们居然把给货车进出的巨大卷帘门给完全堵死了。这一天什么工作都没干，而且我觉得这肯定是个工作日，因为大家都穿着工作服。你穿的不是那种周末休闲、要去逛车库大甩卖的衣服。没错。德怀特首先走向了梅雷迪思的摊位。
She has a crooked sign. The sign says, Jeans $10, you wash them. That was scripted. Oh yeah. There are a bunch of other things on her table. We have some random toys, some bike helmets, some CDs, a basketball, a globe, you know, like the globe of the earth, of the world. Yes.
她立着一块歪歪扭扭的牌子。牌子上写着：牛仔裤10美元，自己洗。这是剧本写好的。哦，是的。她的摊位上还有一大堆其他东西。有一些乱七八糟的玩具、一些自行车头盔、一些CD、一个篮球、一个地球仪，你知道，就是那种地球仪、世界的。是的。
Yes. A stack of blue jeans, like you mentioned, a stuffed deer head and a valley view banner, like a school banner. What are you buying from Meredith's table, I have to ask? Blue jeans. I thought of blue jeans for your mom. Yes. So she could make stuff.
对的。如你所提到的，一叠蓝色牛仔裤、一个塞了填充物的鹿头标本，还有一个山谷景观横幅，就像学校的那种横幅。我得问问，你会从梅雷迪思的摊位上买什么？蓝色牛仔裤。我想到了用蓝色牛仔裤给你妈妈做东西。对。这样她就可以做手工艺品了。
My mom makes throw blankets out of old blue jeans. She also makes these adorable Christmas trees out of old denim. I thought pile of denim, I need to buy that and send it to Birdie. I have never, ever gotten rid of a pair of blue jeans my whole life because my mom's like, I can use that. Well, Dwight is going to trade, Meredith, a thumbtack for her crooked sign for a half of a candle. It's a used candle.
我妈妈用旧蓝色牛仔裤做盖毯。她还用旧牛仔布做这些超级可爱的圣诞树。我想，这一堆牛仔布，我得买下来寄给伯蒂。我这辈子从来没有扔过一条蓝色牛仔裤，因为我妈总是说：“这我能用。”好吧，德怀特要用一个图钉跟梅雷迪思交换她那块歪歪扭扭的牌子，换半根蜡烛。这是一根用过的蜡烛。
Yeah. He's like, listen, you're not going to sell anything with that crooked sign. This candle's been used. What do you care? Meanwhile, Kevin's going to walk up to Michael and Holly's table. He is very interested in that St. Pauli girl light up sign. Remember the one that Jan and Michael got into a huge fight about at dinner party. But it's very clear that Michael does not want to sell it.
是的。他说，听着，你挂着那个歪歪扭扭的牌子什么也卖不出去。这蜡烛是用过的。你在乎什么？与此同时，凯文走向了迈克尔和霍莉的摊位。他对那个圣保利女孩的霓虹发光招牌非常感兴趣。还记得简和迈克尔在晚宴派对上为它大吵了一架的那块吗？但很显然，迈克尔一点也不想卖掉它。
Oh no, no. Michael's like, it's priceless. Holly says $10 to which Michael says, no, I paid $500 for that and Kevin offers him $200. Insane. Michael says, no, $500, Holly says $20, Kevin says $45, Michael says, get lost. And then Michael says, that's how you do it. Yeah.
哦不，不。迈克尔觉得，这是无价之宝。霍莉说10美元，对此迈克尔说，不，我当年花500美元买的，然后凯文出价200美元。疯了。迈克尔说，不，500美元，霍莉说20美元，凯文说45美元，迈克尔说，滚一边去。然后迈克尔说，这才是砍价的正确方式。是的。
And then this next line, I had to rewind it to make sure I heard it correctly. Holly says, you know, we don't have to sell that if you don't want to. If it's a problem with the neon, I can have my neon guy look at it. I was like, wait, Holly has a neon guy? What is a neon guy? Why does she have one? I have so many questions. How much neon is she getting worked on?
接下来这句台词，我不得不倒带重听了一遍，以确保我没听错。霍莉说，你知道，如果你不想卖的话，我们没必要卖。如果霓虹灯有什么问题的话，我可以找我认识的修霓虹灯的人来看看。当时我想，等等，霍莉认识修霓虹灯的人？什么叫修霓虹灯的人？她为什么会认识这种人？我有太多的问题了。她到底有多少霓虹灯需要维修啊？
I don't know, but it's just another example of how she's perfect for Michael. Well they get into this conversation about just in case. Yeah. Holly tells Michael, you know, we can put the sign in storage instead of selling it just in case. Because he says it belongs in a bachelor pad. Yeah. Just in case he wants to go back to that.
我不知道，但这只是她绝对是迈克尔的绝配的又一个例子。然后他们开始讨论起“以防万一”这个话题。是的。霍莉告诉迈克尔，你知道的，我们可以把招牌放进储藏室而不是卖掉它，以防万一。因为迈克尔说这东西只适合单身汉公寓。是的。以防他以后想搬回那种地方去。
Michael says he doesn't have it just in case and neither does Holly. It's this really sweet moment. But right at this sweet moment, a woman walks up and asks about a slip-and-slide and Michael tells her to get lost. This slip-and-slide woman was played by Barbara Bennett and we had to get permission from the slip-and-slide people. Meg Shave had to call the COO of WAMMO and they said yes, we could both say slip-and-slide and show a slip-and-slide.
迈克尔说他留着它并不是为了以防万一，霍莉也不是。这是一个非常温馨的时刻。但就在这个温馨的时刻，一个女人走过来询问关于滑水道的事，迈克尔直接叫她滚一边去。这个滑水道女人由芭芭拉·贝内特饰演，我们不得不获得滑水道公司的许可。梅格·谢夫不得不打电话给WAMMO的首席运营官，他们说可以，我们既可以提到滑水道，也可以展示滑水道。
Thank you WAMMO folks. Mm-hmm. Here's the rest of the stuff at Michael and Holly's table. We have a lobster hat, we have a sombrero, we have another straw hat, we have a mini slot machine, we have a tambourine, this slip-and-slide like you mentioned, and a bunch of other board games. It looks like one that says Shark Game, I don't know if you guys caught that, one that says Margaritaville, Coffee Mugs, that St. Pauli girl neon sign, and of course the Cracked
谢谢WAMMO的朋友们。嗯-hmm。以下是迈克尔和霍莉摊位上的其余东西。我们有一顶龙虾帽、一顶墨西哥草帽、另一顶草帽、一台迷你老虎机、一面手鼓、就像你提到的那个滑水道，还有一堆其他棋盘游戏。看起来有一个叫“鲨鱼游戏”，我不知道你们有没有注意到，还有一个叫“玛格丽塔酒”，咖啡马克杯，那个圣保利女孩霓虹招牌，当然还有那台摔碎的等离子电视。
Plasma TV. We got a letter from Kaylee N. in Indonesia. Apakabar, Kaylee! Who said, I love that you can see the Cracked Plasma TV from the Dinner Party episode. I would like to applaud the crew for their consistency. Yes, I thought that was amazing. The next scene after this is Michael calling Holly's dad. You know, he knows now there's no Justin Case, they're both in it to win it, which by the
我们收到了来自印度尼西亚的凯莉·N.的来信。Apakabar, Kaylee! 她说：“我太喜欢你们能看到《晚宴派对》那一集里那台摔碎的等离子电视了。我要为剧组的这种前后呼应鼓掌。”是的，我觉得这太神奇了。接下来的一个场景是迈克尔给霍莉的爸爸打电话。你知道的，他现在知道已经没有什么“以防万一”了，他们两个是真心奔着结婚去的，顺便说一句，这也是我当时对乔希说过的话。我有跟你讲过这个故事吗？
way is what I said to Josh. Have I ever told you this story? No, you said, I'm in it to win it or you said I have no Justin Case? I said, I said, babe, I don't know about you, but I'm in it to win it, and he said, I'm in it to win it. Oh, that's so sweet! And I said, all right, let's do this, and then a few months later he proposed to me. I want to get you like glasses that say, in it to win it or something for your anniversary,
没有，你说的是“我是真心奔着结婚去的”还是说“我没有什么以防万一”？我说，我说，宝贝，我不知道你怎么想，反正我是真心奔着结婚去的，而他说，我也是真心奔着结婚去的。哦，太甜了！我说，好吧，那就这么办吧，然后几个月后他就向我求婚了。我想给你定制一副眼镜，上面写着“真心奔着结婚去的”或者类似的话作为你的结婚纪念日礼物，
now that I know this. Anyway, I just thought of that when they were like, no Justin Case, I was like, I'm in it to win it. But yes, Michael is very confident now about proposing to Holly, and he is going to call her dad and ask for her hand in marriage, and Jenna, I really felt like we needed to hear how he went about this, please. Yes, hello, Mr. Flax, this is Michael Scott, your daughter's boss. I am calling because I am going to have to fire your daughter, Holly, because she's such
既然我知道了这回事。总之，当他们说“没有以防万一”时，我一下子就想到了这个，我当时就想，我是真心奔着结婚去的。不过是的，迈克尔现在非常有信心向霍莉求婚，他要打电话给她爸爸请求把女儿嫁给他，珍娜，我真的觉得我们需要听听他是怎么处理这件事的，请放出来吧。是的，你好，弗拉克先生，我是迈克尔·斯科特，你女儿的老板。我打电话是因为我不得不把你女儿霍莉给解雇了，因为她是个极其糟糕的
a terrible employee. I'm just kidding, I'm kidding, I'm actually calling because I'm in love with her. I love your daughter, and I have for some time, and I would like to discuss my intentions with you, which are to ask her to marry me, and I was just hoping that you would give me your approval, and this isn't a joke. So call me back when you get this, and I look forward to speaking. Thank you. I love the reveal that it was a voice message.
员工。我开玩笑的，我开玩笑的，我其实打电话是因为我爱上她了。我爱你的女儿，而且这种感情已经有一段时间了，我想跟你讨论一下我的意图，那就是请求娶她为妻，我只是希望能得到你的批准，这不是个玩笑。所以你看到留言后给我回电话，我期待着与你交谈。谢谢。我太喜欢这个最后揭晓其实是语音留言的设定了。
I just cringe that he is still fake firing people. When has that worked for you, Michael? Never. He cannot get past that bit. And he's so tickled by it. But yes, he left all of that on a voicemail, which is another thing that he's done over the years. He's left really personal stuff on an answering machine.
只要一想到他还在假装解雇别人，我就尴尬得脚趾抠地。迈克尔，这招什么时候对谁管用过？从来没有。他就是过不去这个梗。而且他自己还乐在其中。不过是的，他把所有这些话都留在了语音信箱里，这也是他这些年一直在做的事。他总是在电话答录机里留下非常私人的内容。
Back at the garage sale, Dwight has come up to Kelly's table, and he manages to get a trade of the candle, the used candle, for a book collection for her Helen Fielding and Jennifer Weiner book collection by convincing Kelly that this half-used candle will make Ryan jealous. I would like to point out, I think Dwight is playing apples to apples here. What's apples to apples? Apples to apples is a board game. It's fantastic, and you basically play the player.
回到车库大甩卖现场，德怀特来到了凯利的摊位，他成功用那根蜡烛（用过的蜡烛）换到了一套书，换来了她的海伦·菲尔丁和詹妮弗·韦纳的书籍收藏，他说服凯利说这根用了一半的蜡烛会让瑞安吃醋。我想指出的是，我觉得德怀特在这里玩的是“苹果对苹果”的游戏。什么是“苹果对苹果”？“苹果对苹果”是一个桌游。它太棒了，你基本上是在跟玩家斗智斗勇。
You try to guess how you're going to answer, Jenna, and if I guess correctly, then I win. So he's playing the player. So for anyone who doesn't know, Helen Fielding is an English novelist and screenwriter. She's best known for creating the Bridget Jones series, and Jennifer Weiner is an American writer who, among other things, wrote the novel In Her Shoes, which was made into a movie starring Cameron Diaz and Toni Collette and Shirley McClain. And according to Randy, Meg said, we were allowed to verbally reference the books only. We were not allowed to show them.
你试着去猜你会怎么回答，珍娜，如果我猜对了，那我就赢了。所以他是在跟人博弈。所以对于任何不知道的人来说，海伦·菲尔丁是一位英国小说家和编剧。她最为人所知的是创作了《布奇·琼斯日记》系列，而詹妮弗·韦纳是一位美国作家，她写过的小说包括《穿靴子的猫》（译者注：应为《In Her Shoes》，常译为《偷鞋情缘》），该书被改编成了由卡梅隆·迪亚兹、托妮·科莱特和雪莉·麦克雷恩主演的电影。根据兰迪的说法，梅格表示，我们只被允许口头提及这些书。我们不被允许展示它们。
There's your clearance report. So many rules. Well, let's talk about what else was on Kelly's table. It looked like she had a rack of clothes next to her table. It looks to be maybe a statue of Vishnu, some type of dragon head, a wooden jewelry box, an old alarm clock, three handheld fans, Jenna. You would have bought the fans. I would have loved one of those fans.
这就是你的清关报告。规矩真多。好吧，我们来聊聊凯利摊位上还有什么。看起来她摊位旁边挂着一排衣服。那似乎是一尊毗湿奴雕像、某种龙首、一个木制首饰盒、一个旧闹钟、三个手持小风扇，珍娜。你肯定会买那些小风扇。我一定会超爱其中一把风扇的。
Looked like some fabric, a palm reading statue, then she had two of these like plastic table centerpieces for like a party, a disco ball, and a bunch of miniature glass vases. I think I would have bought the most items at Kelly's table. I think I might have found something on the clothing rack. I could imagine going through there and finding a really great brightly colored blazer. I would have taken the book collection that Dwight just took. Definitely one of the fans. I don't know.
看起来还有一些布料、一尊看手相的雕像，然后她有两个那种用于派对的塑料桌子核心装饰品、一个迪斯科球，以及一堆迷你玻璃花瓶。我觉得我在凯利的摊位上会买最多的东西。我觉得我可能会在衣架上找到点什么。我能想象自己在那里面翻找，然后找到一件非常棒的颜色鲜艳的西装外套。我会拿走德怀特刚刚换走的那套书。绝对会拿一把风扇。不知道。
Maybe the palm reading thing. If I was in a mood, you know, when you go to a garage sale, sometimes suddenly you're like, I'm a different person. I need a palm reading kit. You're absolutely right. Because as I look at her table, my first thought was I have to have that disco ball. Right? What are you doing with that?
也许还有那个看手相的东西。如果你当时那个心情的话，你知道的，当你去逛车库大甩卖时，有时你突然就会觉得，我换了个人。我需要一套看手相的工具。你完全说得对。因为当我看着她的摊位时，我的第一反应是我必须拥有那个迪斯科球。对吧？你拿那玩意儿要干嘛？
Why do you need it? Where am I putting that? Next up is Kevin's table. Andy and Daryl walk up to check out what's there and guess what they see? A board game. They really want to play. Dallas. Yes.
你为什么需要它？我要把它挂哪儿去？接下来是凯文的摊位。安迪和达里尔走过去看看那里有什么，猜猜他们看到了什么？一个桌游。他们真的很想玩。达拉斯。是的。
This Dallas board game is real. It was scripted and Phil Shea found it on eBay. Here are some details. It was made in 1980. It's for ages 12 and up, two to seven players, two to seven, not two to eight. Yeah. What an odd choice cut off. The playing time is around 120 minutes, 120 minutes, two hours.
这个《达拉斯》桌游是真实的。这是剧本写好的，菲尔·谢伊在eBay上找到了它。这里有一些细节。它于1980年制造。适合12岁及以上年龄，2到7名玩家，2到7人，不是2到8人。是的。多么奇怪的人数限制切断点。游戏时长大约120分钟，120分钟，两个小时。
It takes a long time to play the Dallas board game. Holy crap. Here's the quote on the box. Take on the role of a character from the TV series in a race to amass the most wealth. That's the idea. Let me tell you, this was the biggest clearance issue for Meg. Really? Because the game had been discontinued.
玩一局《达拉斯》桌游要花很长时间。我的天呐。盒子上是这么引述的：“扮演电视剧中的角色，在积累最多财富的竞赛中一较高下。”就是这个概念。让我告诉你，这是梅格遇到的最大的版权清关问题。真的吗？因为这款游戏已经停产了。
It was not being sold anymore. Oh, so she had to like do a lot of hunting to figure out who the heck to reach out to? Yeah, like who has the rights to this game? Yeah. Well, it was originally made by a company called Yakinto Publishing, but that company had been sold to Cardamundi, who told them that the game was probably commissioned by Laura Martellivision, which is who made the TV show. And maybe they owned the rights to the game, but Laura Martellivision no longer existed.
它已经不再售卖了。哦，所以她不得不进行大量的搜寻，来弄清楚到底该联系谁？对啊，比如到底谁拥有这款游戏的版权？嗯，它最初是由一家名为Yakinto Publishing的公司制作的，但该公司后来被卖给了一家叫Cardamundi的公司，后者告诉他们，这款游戏可能是由制作这部电视剧的洛里·马特利维vision公司委托制作的。也许他们拥有该游戏的版权，但洛里·马特利维vision公司已经不复存在了。
It had been absorbed by Warner Brothers and then dissolved. So Cardamundi said, we don't know if we have the rights, but sure, use it. I was going to say at that point, can you just say we'll roll the dice and see if someone comes after us? Yes. I think that's basically what they did. I think this Dallas board game nowadays would be called succession. Yeah, exactly.
它被华纳兄弟收购然后解散了。所以Cardamundi说，我们不知道我们是否拥有版权，但没关系，你们用吧。我本来想说，在那点上，你们难道不能就说我们抛个硬币碰碰运气，看看有没有人来找我们麻烦吗？是的。我觉得他们基本上就是这么干的。我觉得现在这个《达拉斯》桌游会被叫做《继承之战》。是的，完全没错。
Well, here were the other things at Kevin's table. Did you guys see the big train set that went through a mountain? I did. I'm not sure I'm buying anything at Kevin's table. Yeah, it's a tough sell. I think the board game was the best thing. Yeah. Even though it doesn't end up having all the pieces.
好吧，凯文摊位上的其他东西还有这些。你们看到那个穿过一座山的巨大火车模型了吗？看到了。我不确定我在凯文的摊位上会买任何东西。是的，这很难卖出去。我觉得那个桌游是最好的东西。是的。尽管它最后并不包含所有的配件。
Right. Or the instructions. Well, Dwight is going to walk by Jim and Pam's table, and he is very surprised to see a packet of Dr. Copperfield's Miracle Legumes, but Jim won't sell them to Dwight. No. Even though he acquired them under mysterious circumstances, he was in Jamaica when, and a guy knew everything about Jim and then sold him these beans. And when he turned around, the guy was gone, he had disappeared.
或者说明书。好吧，德怀特走过了吉姆和帕姆的摊位，他非常惊讶地看到了一包“铜菲尔德博士的神奇豆子”，但吉姆就是不肯卖给德怀特。不。尽管他是神秘兮兮地弄到这玩意的，他在牙买加的时候，有个人对吉姆的事情了如指掌，然后把这些豆子卖给了他。等他转过身时，那个人已经不见了，消失得无影无踪。
Oh my gosh. Well, there was more to the scene between Dwight and Jim. It's in the shooting draft. It's just a small couplet of dialogue, but I thought it was great. Jim is really trying to bait Dwight, right? And in the shooting draft, he would have also said this, Pam must have put them out. She wants them out of the house. Of course it was Pam.
天呐。好吧，德怀特和吉姆之间的场景其实还有更多内容。它在拍摄剧本里。只是一小段对话，但我觉得太棒了。吉姆真的在试图激怒德怀特，对吧？而在拍摄剧本中，他本来还会说这样的话：肯定是帕姆摆出来的。她想把这些东西清出家门。当然是帕姆干的。
Oh, that's good. Yeah. And Dwight's like, no, terrible try, you know, and he walks away. The next scene, we have Holly back in the annex. She's at her desk. She's on the phone with her parents because Michael has called and her mom's like, what is this about? And Holly says, wait, can I talk to dad?
哦，这句好。是的。而德怀特说，不，这招太烂了，你知道的，然后他走开了。接下来的场景，我们看到霍莉回到了附楼。她坐在办公桌前。她正在跟父母打电话，因为迈克尔打过电话了，而她妈妈说：这到底是怎么回事？霍莉说：等等，我能跟爸爸讲话吗？
Jenna, did you hear what her dad said to her? You know I did, Angela. Oh my gosh. It was so sweet. It was so cute. This is how it read in the script. Holly's mom says, yes, here, and she passes the phone to Holly's dad. Mr. Flack skits on the phone.
珍娜，你听见她爸爸对她说什么了吗？你知道我听见了，安吉拉。哦，天哪。太甜了。太可爱了。剧本里是这样写的。霍莉的妈妈说，好的，给你，然后她把电话递给霍莉的爸爸。弗拉克先生在电话里开玩笑。
Hollis, hi dad. There was a program on TV about India. Okay. Did you connect with Michael? Hollis. Hollis. He calls her Hollis. That was what was on her name plate.
霍莉丝，嗨，爸爸。电视上有个关于印度的节目。好吧。你联系到迈克尔了吗？霍莉丝。霍莉丝。他叫她霍莉丝。她的名牌上就是这么写的。
Yeah. On her desk in the first episode that she was in. Yes. And we were like, oh my gosh, is her name Hollis? It is. It is. It is Hollis. Although I don't know if you notice, the name plate that's on her desk in this scene
对。在她演的第一集里，她的桌子上。是的。当时我们就想，哦，天哪，她叫霍莉丝吗？是的。是的。她叫霍莉丝。虽然我不知道你有没有注意到，这一幕中她桌子上的那个名牌
that's right under her computer monitor says Holly Flack's now. It doesn't say Hollis. Want to give a little shout out to the voice actors here. Holly's mom was voiced by Bonnie Bartlett and her dad was voiced by John O'Leary. Did you see it five minutes and 49 seconds, Jenna? A shot of Holly's Faber Shea egg. Yes. It's right next to her name plate.
就在她电脑显示器下方，上面现在写着“霍莉·弗拉克”。没有写霍莉丝。这里要向配音演员致敬。霍莉的妈妈由邦妮·巴特利特配音，爸爸由约翰·奥利里配音。珍娜，你看到了吗？在5分49秒处。有一个霍莉的法贝热彩蛋的镜头。是的。就在她的名牌旁边。
Yeah. What is this egg? She's not selling it at the garage sale, so it's clearly very important to her. Well if you notice that Pam wasn't with Jim when Dwight walked up to their table, it's because she's grabbing coffee for them at the caffeine corner. She asked which one is decaf, which really pisses Hank off. Well, because he clearly doesn't know and he's going to have to remake the coffees. We had a fan question from Natalie F. in San Antonio, Texas, who said, I love when Pam
对。这是什么蛋？她又不在车库大卖场里卖它，所以显然对她非常重要。如果你注意到德怀特走到他们的桌子旁时，帕姆不在吉姆身边，那是因为她正在咖啡角为他们买咖啡。她问哪一杯是低因咖啡，这真的把汉克惹毛了。嗯，因为他显然不知道，他得重新做咖啡。我们收到了来自德克萨斯州圣安东尼奥的娜塔莉·F的粉丝提问，她说，我喜欢帕姆
asks Hank which coffee is decaf because it shows how much her character has grown and how much confidence she has gained since the Cocktails episode when she had to really challenge herself to take her beer back and ask for a light after she was given the incorrect order. She really pushed herself in that moment and took so much courage and now she doesn't even hesitate to make sure she gets what she wants. Pam's character development is one of the most inspiring things in the series. Go Pam.
问汉克哪杯是低因咖啡，因为这展示了她的角色成长了多少，以及自从在《鸡尾酒》那一集里，她不得不真正挑战自己，在拿到错误订单后把啤酒退回去并要求换一杯清淡啤酒以来，她获得了多少自信。那一刻她真的突破了自己，鼓起了巨大的勇气，而现在她毫不犹豫地确保自己得到想要的东西。帕姆的角色成长是整部剧中最励志的事情之一。加油，帕姆。
Aw. I just loved that letter. I did too. It's such a great observation. Yes. I got another fan question from Rachel P. in Wilmore, Kentucky, who said, I've always noticed in this episode that Pam has started to wear her shirt untucked and that when she orders coffee at Dwight's caffeine corner, she asks Hank which one is decaf.
啊。我太喜欢这封信了。我也是。这是一个非常棒的观察。是的。我还收到了来自肯塔基州威尔莫尔的雷切尔·P的另一个粉丝提问，她说，我一直注意到在这集里，帕姆开始把衬衫下摆放出来，当她在德怀特的咖啡角订咖啡时，她问汉克哪一杯是低因。
Is this a hint that Pam is pregnant after her and Jim's Valentine's Day walk at work? I know that Jenna announced her pregnancy back in May of 2011 and this episode aired in March of 2011. I was just wondering, is the decaf coffee for Pam or Jenna? Well, Rachel, I was pregnant when we were shooting this episode and I had to untuck my shirt so that no one could see my little growing belly. And also no one knew I was pregnant. So all of a sudden, I just stopped tucking in Pam's shirt starting this week.
这是暗示帕姆在和吉姆的情人节工作散步后怀孕了吗？我知道珍娜在2011年5月宣布了怀孕，而这一集是在2011年3月播出的。我只是想知道，那杯低因咖啡是给帕姆的还是给珍娜的？嗯，雷切尔，我们拍摄这一集时我确实怀孕了，我不得不把衬衫下摆放出来，这样就没人能看到我日渐隆起的小腹了。而且当时也没人知道我怀孕了。所以从这周开始，我突然就不把帕姆的衬衫扎进裤子里了。
Not only did you do that, but we've shared this before. You just went and started buying your own shirts to look like Pam's shirts so that people wouldn't know you were going up a size. Yes. At a certain point, untucking my shirt and I was, had been like not zipping my skirt up all the way. I was sort of like safety pinning it. Yeah.
你不仅这么做了，而且我们以前也分享过。你直接去给自己买衣服，买得看起来像帕姆的衬衫，这样别人就不会发现你的尺码变大了。是的。到了一定程度，把衬衫下摆放出来，而且我当时一直没有把裙子拉链完全拉上。我有点像是用别针别着。对。
It was using a safety pin attached to a hair tie. Yes. I showed you that move. And eventually these two tricks weren't working and I went out one weekend and I just bought myself a whole new outfit at J Crew and I insisted that I had to wear it. This is what Pam would wear this episode because if you do a fitting, they know, they measure you in your undies and they're going to see the belly and they're also going to be like, oh yeah.
是用一个别在发绳上的安全别针。是的。我给你看过那一招。最终这两个小把戏不管用了，有一个周末我出去，直接在J Crew给自己买了一整套新衣服，我坚持说我必须穿这套。这一集里帕姆就会穿成这样，因为如果你去做试衣，他们就会知道，他们会量你的内衣尺寸，他们就会看到你的肚子，而且他们也会觉得，哦，对了。
Wow. Jenna, you're totally pregnant and I didn't want to tell people yet. So this was the beginning of my pregnancy hide, Rachel. You totally noticed it. Totally caught that, Rachel. Michael is prepping for his big proposal, which I guess includes a bunch of gasoline that he's pouring around cars. Maybe he's spelling out, will you marry me and gasoline and then he's going to torch
哇，珍娜，你真的怀孕了，而我当时还不想告诉别人。所以这就是我开始隐藏怀孕的时候，雷切尔。你真的注意到了。完全被你发现了，雷切尔。迈克尔正在为他的盛大求婚做准备，我想这其中包含了一大堆他倒在汽车周围的汽油。也许他想用汽油拼出“你愿意嫁给我吗”，然后他打算把它们
it. We don't know because thankfully Pam stops this. Yes. Hopefully you all know that was not gasoline, that was just water. But I loved doing this scene. I had a very hard time not laughing because the way Steve was performing, Michael, so earnest, so earnest. And I have to say, I really love where this ends up going.
点燃。我们不知道，因为谢天谢地，帕姆阻止了这一点。是的。希望你们都知道那不是汽油，那只是水。但我很喜欢拍这场戏。我很难忍住不笑，因为史蒂夫扮演迈克尔的方式，太认真了，太认真了。而且我必须说，我真的很喜欢最后的发展。
Oh, I did too. Well, I guess if you want any pesto or salsa, you better head over to Ryan's table. He is selling Mama Sally's homemade pesto and Señor Chico's hot cha-cha salsa. Yes. The pesto has a photo of Phyllis on it and the salsa has a picture of Oscar. He has a talking head where he explains that his mom makes the best pesto, but she would never sell it even though she'd make a fortune. So he decided, he'll sell it.
哦，我也是。嗯，我想如果你想要任何青酱或莎莎酱，你最好去瑞恩的桌子前。他在卖萨利妈妈的自制青酱和奇科先生的超赞热辣莎莎酱。是的。青酱上面有菲莉丝的照片，莎莎酱上面有奥斯卡的图片。他有一个独白镜头，解释说他妈妈做的青酱最好吃，但她绝不会卖，尽管她能赚一大笔钱。所以他决定，他来卖。
He tricked her into making him hundreds of jars of pesto by telling her he was going to have a pesto party for his friends. And Phyllis just kind of looked like the mom he wanted for the jar. And Ryan says, and my mom was like, oh, okay. In the shooting draft, it says said in like a dumb voice. I am sure you can imagine that this talking head created a back and forth with good old standards and practices. Lip flap.
他骗他妈妈给他做了几百罐青酱，告诉她他要为朋友们办一个青酱派对。而菲莉丝看起来就像他在罐子上想要的妈妈。瑞恩说，我妈就说，好吧。在拍摄剧本里，这里写着要用一种愚蠢的声音说。我敢肯定你们可以想象，这个独白镜头引发了与老古董标准和实践部门的拉锯战。口型瑕疵。
Yep. We got a bleep Ryan's completely with no beginning or end consonant sounds, blur the visible lip flap or stage this. My favorite is when they say the third option is stage this off camera stage a talking head off camera. What is the camera on? What's the camera looking at if he's off camera? I don't know.
对。我们得把瑞恩的整句话消音，去掉所有开头和结尾的辅音，模糊可见的口型或者把这幕移到画外。我最喜欢的是他们说第三个选择是把这幕移到画外，把独白放在画外拍。那镜头拍的是什么？如果他在画外，镜头在看什么？我不知道。
And then of course we turned it in and we got a as previously noted, blur that lip flap. Dwight is still making his trades and his next target is Ryan. Yes, he explains in a talking head that he traded his thumbtack for Meredith's candle. Then he traded the candle for Kelly's crap, which he traded for Phyllis's garbage for Oscars trash for Stanley's crap. What he got from Stanley was an old photo album and he's going to trade that with Ryan in order to, I guess, get some pesto. Yeah.
然后当然我们交片了，结果收到了之前提到过的反馈，模糊那个口型。德怀特还在进行他的交换，他的下一个目标是瑞恩。是的，他在一个独白镜头里解释说，他用他的图钉换了梅雷迪思的蜡烛。然后他用蜡烛换了凯莉的破烂，他又用这个换了菲莉丝的垃圾，换了奥斯卡的废品，换了斯坦利的破烂。他从斯坦利那里得到的是一本旧相册，他打算用这个跟瑞恩交换，我想，是为了换点青酱。对。
That's going to eventually lead him to getting something from Creed and finally a really cute squid that Aaron had. You know, Jenna, at eight minutes and 31 seconds during Dwight's talking head where he's listing all of the trades he made. You can see in the background that both Phyllis and Aaron have wooden spice racks on their tables. Really? Mm-hmm.
这最终会引导他从克里德那里得到一些东西，最后得到一个艾伦有的非常可爱的乌贼。你知道吗，珍娜，在8分31秒德怀特列出他做过的所有交换的独白镜头里，你可以在背景中看到菲莉丝和艾伦的桌子上都有木制的香料架。真的吗？嗯哼。
Well, there was a scene that got deleted where Phyllis is not happy that Aaron is selling the same things that she is. It's in deleted scenes. Phyllis is so perfectly annoyed. This is how it read. Aaron sits at her table, which has a spice rack labeled $10. She looks over to Phyllis's table, where Phyllis is setting up the same exact spice rack offered at the same amount of money.
嗯，有一场被删掉的戏，菲莉丝很不高兴艾伦在卖和她一样的东西。这在删减片段里。菲莉丝恼火得太完美了。剧本是这样写的。艾伦坐在她的桌子旁，桌上放着一个标价10美元的香料架。她看着菲莉丝的桌子，菲莉丝正在摆放完全相同的香料架，标价也一样。
Aaron looks to Phyllis. Looks like we're in the spice district, Phyllis, tightly. Yep. And then later in the episode, you see Aaron slashing the price of hers to $9 to try to undermine Phyllis. Well now Dwight is going to return to Jim's table and the beans are still there. Yeah. Professor Copperfield's Miracle Legumes.
艾伦看着菲莉丝。看来我们身处香料区了，菲莉丝，语气生硬地说。对。然后在这集的后面，你会看到艾伦把她那里的价格降到9美元，试图打压菲莉丝。好了，现在德怀特要回到吉姆的桌子旁，那些豆子还在那里。对。科普菲尔德教授的奇迹豆。
Jim's going to destroy them. He has had it. He crumples them up. He stomps on them. He's got to throw them in the trash. Let's talk about what else is on Jim and Pam's table for a second. Please. It looks like a glass lamp fixture, just the top of a lamp.
吉姆要把它们毁了。他受够了。他把它们揉成一团。他踩在它们上面。他得把它们扔进垃圾桶。我们花一秒钟聊聊吉姆和帕姆桌上还有什么。请便。看起来像是一个玻璃灯具，只有一个灯罩顶部。
Oh, no, no. That's, you know, the thing that you hang from the ceiling. Was it, I wasn't sure. A hundred percent. I swear I had one of those in my house growing up. Oh yeah. It was over our breakfast table. Right.
哦，不，不。那是，你知道的，从天花板上垂下来的那种东西。是吗，我不太确定。百分之百。我发誓我长大的家里就有一个。哦，对。它在我们早餐桌上方。没错。
And you're a breakfast nook. Yes. So we have the glass lamp fixture, a bike helmet, golf clubs, a bird feeder, a big green ball. What is that big green ball? I don't know. Legumes, did you catch Jim and Pam's clown painting? Yes, I did.
在你们的早餐角落。是的。所以我们有玻璃灯具、自行车头盔、高尔夫球杆、喂鸟器、一个绿色的大球。那个绿色的大球是什么？我不知道。豆子，你注意到吉姆和帕姆的小丑画了吗？是的，我注意到了。
We also got a fan catch from Haley W. and Charlotte, North Carolina, who said Jim and Pam also have some clown figurines for sale. Yes. And they're really creepy. They're little and they're all stacked in a row. Yeah. Haley said, did Jim's parents also have creepy clown figurines? And if so, why are Jim's parents obsessed with clowns?
我们还收到了来自北卡罗来纳州夏洛特的黑莉·W的粉丝发现，她说吉姆和帕姆还有一些小丑雕像在出售。是的。而且它们真的很诡异。它们很小，整齐地排成一排。对。黑莉说，吉姆的父母也有诡异的小丑雕像吗？如果是这样，为什么吉姆的父母对小丑这么着迷？
And why did Jim and Pam keep these for so long? Haven't they been living this house for a while now? I have so many questions. Maybe this clown obsession of his parents explains why he has to prank Dwight. That's deep, Angela. I know. I feel like that would be something Jim would talk about in his therapy. I mean, maybe his parents pranked him his whole life with creepy clowns.
为什么吉姆和帕姆把这些留了这么久？他们在这栋房子里住了有一段时间了吧？我有这么多问题。也许他父母对小丑的这种痴迷解释了为什么他非得捉弄德怀特。这很有深度，安吉拉。我知道。我觉得这会是吉姆会在心理治疗中谈论的事情。我是说，也许他的父母一辈子都用诡异的小丑捉弄他。
What would you buy from Jim and Pam's table, Angela? Anything? Come on. Come on. Who are you talking to? What? A bird feeder. Oh yeah, that's true.
安吉拉，你会从吉姆和帕姆的桌子上买什么？随便什么？得了吧。得了吧。你在跟谁说话？什么？喂鸟器。哦对，那是真的。
Of course. What am I thinking? What are you thinking? Nothing. I mean, for the first time, I don't want anything from this table, really. Maybe I would buy a creepy clown figurine and then I would wrap it up as a white elephant gift. There you go.
当然。我在想什么呢？你在想什么？没什么。我是说，有生以来第一次，我真的什么都不想从这张桌子上买。也许我会买一个诡异的小丑雕像，然后把它包装成白象礼物送出去。这就对了。
Pam is now going to invite Michael to the conference room for a meeting he called, but he doesn't remember calling any meeting. My favorite thing is when he walks in the room and he's like, hey, everybody, I just wanted to talk to you. We're going to talk about recycling. And Pam's like Michael. He just went right into some like shtick. Pam is going to start to say to Michael, so look, about this proposal, he's like, no,
帕姆现在要邀请迈克尔去会议室开一个他召集的会议，但他根本不记得自己召集过什么会议。我最喜欢的是他走进房间时说，嘿，大家好，我只是想跟你们谈谈。我们要谈谈回收利用。而帕姆说，迈克尔。他直接开始背起某种台词了。帕姆刚要对迈克尔说，听着，关于这个求婚，他却说，不，
no, no, you will not talk me out of this. And Pam's like, she's perfect for you. Oscar says she's the one. Jim and Ryan, they're all like, she's amazing. And Pam explains they just want to help him with the proposal to make it safe and responsible and realistic and doable. And Michael says, I had a great idea until you ruined it. And then Oscar has the speech and I loved it so much.
不，不，你休想说服我放弃这个。帕姆觉得，她对你来说太完美了。奥斯卡说她就是那个人。吉姆和瑞恩，他们都说，她太棒了。帕姆解释说他们只是想帮他策划求婚，让求婚变得安全、负责任、现实且可行。而迈克尔说，我本来有个绝妙的主意，直到被你们毁了。然后奥斯卡发表了一段演讲，我太喜欢了。
Oscar says, here's how you do it. You take her out to dinner, go down on one knee. If you were in costume, you did something wrong. If at any point you find yourself tying a ring to a dog's collar, stop and look at yourself. We had a fan question from Carrie B in Minnesota who asked in the conference room scene where Michael is figuring out how to propose to Holly who decided which actors got to be in the room. Ryan seemed like an odd choice given his not so great history with Michael.
奥斯卡说，你是这么做的。你带她去吃晚饭，单膝跪地。如果你穿着戏服，你就做错了。如果你发现自己在任何时候把戒指绑在狗项圈上，停下来审视一下自己。我们收到了来自明尼苏达州的凯瑞·B的粉丝提问，她问在会议室的那场戏里，迈克尔正在琢磨如何向霍莉求婚，是谁决定让哪些演员留在房间里的？考虑到瑞恩和迈克尔之间不太美好的历史，他似乎是一个奇怪的选择。
Well, Carrie, the idea here was that Pam chose who would be in the room based on who would help her achieve her goal of this safe, doable, realistic proposal. So I think she picked Jim and Oscar because they are the most level headed thinkers. And I think she picked Ryan because Michael respects Ryan's opinion. And if Ryan agrees, then Michael will believe it's cool. Right. You know, the scene ended with an extra beat. It's in the shooting draft.
嗯，凯瑞，这里的想法是，帕姆根据谁能帮她实现“安全、可行、现实的求婚”这个目标来选择留在房间里的人。所以我认为她选择了吉姆和奥斯卡，因为他们是最头脑冷静的思想者。我认为她选择瑞恩是因为迈克尔尊重瑞恩的意见。如果瑞恩同意了，那么迈克尔就会相信这很酷。没错。你知道，这场戏结尾多了一个节拍。这在拍摄剧本里。
It didn't make it into the episode. But as they're wrapping up, Ryan's like, hey, next time could we, you know, get lunch for one of these meetings? And Michael's like, yeah, yeah, of course, and he starts listing out the food he'll get. And Ryan storms out and goes, I can't eat any of that. It's like such an odd way to end the scene. Well, lady, I think we should take a break. And when we come back, Kevin and Andy and Darryl have started playing the game of Dallas.
它没有被剪进正片里。但当他们收尾时，瑞恩说，嘿，下次我们能，你知道的，为这些会议订个午餐吗？迈克尔说，行，行，当然，然后他开始列举他要买的食物。瑞恩气冲冲地走出去说，我什么都吃不了。这真是一种奇怪的收尾方式。好了，女士们，我想我们该休息一下了。当我们回来时，凯文、安迪和达里尔开始玩达拉斯游戏。
They have some sort of wager on the line. They've got a couple of money. And we're going to learn what's on Phyllis's table. And we're going to get to that ultimate proposal. We are back and Holly is now shopping at Phyllis's table. She wants to know if most of these items were Phyllis's mom's stuff. And this leads to a really moving conversation where Holly says to Phyllis, how is she doing? Sort of implying that Phyllis has maybe shared that her mom is now in a home.
他们押了一些赌注。他们有一些钱。我们要看看菲莉丝的桌子上有什么。我们要迎来那场终极求婚。我们回来了，霍莉现在正在菲莉丝的桌子前购物。她想知道这些东西大部分是不是菲莉丝妈妈的东西。这引发了一场非常感人的对话，霍莉对菲莉丝说，她现在怎么样？这似乎暗示菲莉丝可能分享过她的妈妈现在住进了疗养院。
And you know, Holly wants to know, when do you know if it's the right time? And Phyllis shares with her, if you're waiting for your parents to come to you, that's not what's going to happen. But that her mom is doing better now. And it's a very touching scene. And it ends with Phyllis saying, I have a box of bras. Would you like to look at them? And Holly immediately says, yes, yeah.
你知道的，霍莉想知道，你怎么知道什么时候才是正确的时机？菲莉丝跟她分享说，如果你在等你的父母来找你，那不会发生。但她的妈妈现在好多了。这是一个非常感人的场景。以菲莉丝说的一句话结尾，我有一盒文胸。你想看看吗？霍莉立刻说，好啊，好啊。
Here are the other items on Phyllis's table. The spice rack, as we know, lace curtains and table linens. Those were written in the shooting draft that she had to have table linens and lace curtains. Fake flower arrangements, Jenna. It looks like a makeup mirror, some jewelry, and of course, a box of bras. What would you have bought at Phyllis's table? Was the makeup mirror one of the like magnifying makeup mirrors? It looks like one of the ones that's like, it's like an oval and it stands on your table
以下是菲莉丝桌上的其他物品。香料架，如我们所知，蕾丝窗帘和桌布。拍摄剧本里写着她必须有桌布和蕾丝窗帘。假花艺，珍娜。看起来像是一个化妆镜，一些首饰，当然还有一盒文胸。你在菲莉丝的桌子上会买什么？那个化妆镜是那种放大化妆镜吗？看起来像是那种椭圆形的、立在桌子上的
and it looks like it flips for the magnified side to the other side. I'm having a problem right now, which is that without my glasses on, I can't see my face very well. So I'm kind of putting makeup on a blur. And the other day, I held up my glasses so that I could see my eyebrows and oh my gosh, they were the hottest of messes. And then though, when I took off my glasses, they looked great. And I can't tweeze my brows because in order to tweeze my brows, I have to take off my
而且看起来可以翻转，一面是放大镜的镜面。我现在遇到了一个问题，那就是不戴眼镜我根本看不清自己的脸。所以我化起妆来有点像是在模糊中进行。前几天，我举起眼镜为了能看清自己的眉毛，哦，天哪，简直是一团糟。然后呢，当我摘下眼镜时，它们看起来又很棒。而且我没法修眉毛，因为为了修眉毛，我必须摘下
glasses. It was a whole thing, I eventually managed to get the tweezers underneath my glasses while wearing them. Long story short, I think I need to do the magnified makeup mirror thing. It's time. It's time. Let me tell you, I have one that I hold with my hand, but then that's also kind of tricky. And I remember years ago, my mom got a super magnified mirror that lit up.
眼镜。说来话长，最后我设法把镊子伸到戴着眼镜的镜片下面。长话短说，我想我需要弄个放大化妆镜了。是时候了。是时候了。我跟你说，我有一个手持的，但那个也挺棘手的。我记得多年前，我妈妈买了一个会发光的超大放大镜。
Yeah. It's on an accordion arm and my dad screwed it into the wall next to her little vanity area in their bathroom and she could pull it out. Like in a hotel. Hotels have those. Yes. I love it when I go to a hotel. My brows after I've stayed in a hotel.
对。它装在一个手风琴式的支架上，我爸爸把它钉在她浴室里梳妆台旁边的墙上，她可以把它拉出来。就像酒店里那样。酒店都有那种。是的。我特别喜欢去酒店。我住过酒店后的眉毛。
Forget about it. Amazing. Amazing. You look like a different person. I do. I can tell when you've been on vacation because you look a little tidier. Well, I guess that's what I would buy. What about you, Ange?
简直了。太绝了。太绝了。你看上去像换了个人。我确实是。我能看出来你什么时候去度假了，因为你看上去清爽了一些。好吧，我想这就是我会买的。你呢，安吉？
Oh, you know. I love some table linens. I would take a look at those. That was my second choice. Well, now we're going to go back to the conference room and we're still trying to figure out how is Michael going to propose to Holly. I really loved this line where they're trying to figure out about blogging. We want to know what do the blogs say.
哦，你知道的。我很喜欢桌布。我会去看看那些。那是我的第二选择。好吧，现在我们要回到会议室，我们还在想办法弄清楚迈克尔要怎么向霍莉求婚。我真的很喜欢这段台词，他们试图弄清楚关于博客的事。我们想知道博客上是怎么说的。
Yeah. Pam says, Ryan, didn't you read in one of your blogs that animals are out? Yeah. And Ryan says, blogs are out. But people are texting each other that animals are out. Yeah. I loved that. I loved it.
对。帕姆说，瑞恩，你难道没在你的某个博客上看到动物已经过时了吗？对。瑞恩说，博客已经过时了。但人们正在互发短信说动物已经过时了。对。我太喜欢了。我太喜欢了。
Michael has a great idea. It involves a corpse. Yeah. Throwing a corpse off the roof. It's going to hit the ground. The head will pop off and then that is going to lead him to his line. Are you ready? I lost my head when I fell in love with you.
迈克尔有个绝妙的主意。这涉及一具尸体。对。从屋顶扔下一具尸体。它会砸到地面。脑袋会飞出去，然后这就会引出他的台词。准备好了吗？当我坠入爱河时，我失去了理智。
It'll be easy enough to get a corpse, he says. So this is when he gets out the ring and it's, I mean, Pam's reaction, Jenna, you were so funny. You were like, holy s**t, is that real? And then Michael says, yeah, three year salary. Let me start with this standards and practices. Of course, same note, bleep Pam's s**t remark completely with no beginning or end consonant sounds and blur the visible lip flap or stage off camera.
他说，弄一具尸体很容易的。所以就在这时他拿出了戒指，天哪，帕姆的反应，珍娜，你太搞笑了。你当时说，卧槽，那是真的吗？然后迈克尔说，对，三年的薪水。先说说审查和标准部门。当然，老规矩，把帕姆的那个脏话完全消音，不留任何开头或结尾的辅音，并模糊可见的口型或者移到画外。
And again, after we turned in the cut, we got the as previously noted. So the box that is holding Holly's engagement ring, the ring box, the ring box is from a real life Scranton jewelry store called Bacardo Jewelers. No way. Here's what it says on their website. Our store is a 4,000 plus square foot building on the corner of Jefferson Avenue and Spruce Street in historic downtown Scranton. We have free store side parking.
而且，在我们交片之后，我们又收到了之前提到过的反馈。所以，装着霍莉订婚戒指的那个盒子，戒指盒，这个戒指盒来自斯克兰顿的一家现实生活中的珠宝店，名叫巴卡多珠宝店。不会吧。这是他们网站上的介绍。我们的店是一栋4000多平方英尺的建筑，位于历史悠久的斯克兰顿市中心杰斐逊大道和云杉街的拐角处。我们有免费的店边停车场。
We also have a refreshment bar with a flat screen TV. Hey. And it looked like on their website, they're really known for selling luxury watches. They sell other jewelry, but they're really proud of their watch sales. Sandy Bacardo was the founder, started the jewelry business in 1938. He eventually opened a jewelry repair trade shop, which he had for many years. Then in the late 1960s, he opened the first retail jewelry store on Washington Avenue. He was joined by his two sons.
我们还有一个带纯平电视的茶水吧。嘿。从他们的网站上看，他们似乎以销售奢侈手表而闻名。他们也卖其他珠宝，但他们对自己的手表销量感到非常自豪。桑迪·巴卡多是创始人，于1938年开办了这家珠宝生意。他最终开了一家珠宝维修店，经营了多年。然后在20世纪60年代后期，他在华盛顿大街开办了第一家零售珠宝店。他的两个儿子也加入了进来。
And then the Bacardo family purchased a building on Spruce Street. They stayed there till 2007. And then in January of 2008, they got this big freestanding building with the refreshment bar and flat screen TV. So they're on their third generation of being jewelers, having the Bacardo jewelry store. Well, congratulations on your new building. I have a question for you, Bacardo folks. Do you have a spot where Jen and I can record our podcast?
然后巴卡多家族在云杉街买了一栋建筑。他们在那里一直待到2007年。然后在2008年1月，他们买下了这栋带茶点吧和纯平电视的大型独立建筑。所以他们已经是第三代珠宝商了，经营着巴卡多的珠宝店。嗯，恭喜你们有了新建筑。我有个问题想问你们巴卡多家族。你们这里有没有一个地方，能让珍和我录制我们的播客？
Yeah, you have a very large building. It sounds like maybe. Maybe we could have our own spot. I want to point out two tables we have not visited. Okay. Andy's table has a big wooden decorative sailboat, a Cornell banner, what I think looks like a trombone, an accordion and a sailboat steer wheel, you know, that you use to steer the boat.
对，你们的建筑非常大。听起来好像……也许我们可以有自己的专属地方。我想指出两张我们还没参观过的桌子。好吧。安迪的桌子上有一个大型木制装饰帆布船，一面康奈尔大学的旗帜，一个我看起来像长号的东西，一个手风琴，还有一个帆布船舵，你知道的，就是用来掌舵的那种。
What do you call that? I don't know. It's a big wood one. You're just gesturing it, which is really cute. I'm like, you're tending to drive a, I'm like, I'm a pirate. A steering wheel. Yeah. Right?
那个叫什么来着？我不知道。是一个很大的木制品。你刚才还在用手比划，真的好可爱。我感觉你好像在开……我感觉我像个海盗。一个船舵。对吧？
Yeah. Like the wood one. Yeah. And you just spun it. You just spun it. Also, it said in the shooting draft that Andy would have a stack of colorful sweaters. Oh, that tracks. Tracks.
对。就像那个木制的。对。而且你刚刚转动了它。你刚刚转动了它。另外，拍摄剧本里写过，安迪会有一堆色彩斑斓的毛衣。哦，这很符合人设。符合人设。
Jenna, what would you get from Andy's table? Maybe that wheel. I could see myself doing something like hanging it on my wall. If I'm going with a nautical theme. I don't know where I'm doing this, but, you know, I did hang a giant fork and spoon in my kitchen. A giant wooden fork and spoon like they have in the TV show, Everybody Loves Raymond. My grandmother had the same fork and spoon.
珍娜，你会从安迪的桌子上拿什么？也许是那个舵。我觉得自己会做一些把它挂在墙上的事情。如果我要走航海主题的话。我不知道自己为什么要这么做，但是，你知道的，我曾经在厨房里挂过一个巨大的叉子和勺子。就像电视剧《人人都爱雷蒙德》里那种巨大的木制叉子和勺子。我外婆也有同款叉子和勺子。
My grandmother also had a giant fork and spoon on her wall. What was that decor choice back in the day? But you're sticking with it. I'm like, I am bringing it into this new century. What about you? What would you buy? Well, Jenna, I know you know that I moved around a lot as a kid. I was often the new kid.
我外婆的墙上也挂着一个巨大的叉子和勺子。以前到底是什么审美装饰啊？但你还是坚持用它。我想说，我要把它带进这个新世纪。你呢？你会买什么？嗯，珍娜，我知道你懂的，我小时候经常搬家。我经常是学校里的新转学生。
One of those times when I was new at a school, I decided, and Jenna, I don't know if you know this, to go out for the marching band, I thought it might be a way to meet people. You were in the marching band? What did you play? Were you a baton twirler or were you an instrument player? I didn't know how to play any instruments. So what did you do in it? They assigned me to the section that had the fewest people, which was trombone.
有一次我在一个学校当新生的时候，我决定——珍娜，我不知道你知不知道——去参加仪仗乐队，我觉得这可能是认识新朋友的一种方式。你参加过仪仗乐队？你吹什么乐器？你是挥指挥棒的，还是乐器演奏员？我当时根本不会玩任何乐器。那你去里面干嘛？他们把我分到了人数最少的那组，也就是长号。
You play the trombone? I sat next to who ended up being my best friend, Shannon, who was very tall and could play the trombone. I didn't even reach the seventh position, you know, that far out position. I don't know anything about the trombone. I was sitting next to this guy named Bill, and I said to him, I think you're supposed to be in a different position on the trombone. And he goes, oh, I just play F the whole time.
你会吹长号？我坐在最后成为我最好朋友的香农旁边，她个子很高，会吹长号。我当时甚至都够不到第七把位，你知道的，就是那种伸得特别远的把位。我对长号一无所知。我当时坐在一个叫比尔的家伙旁边，我对他说，我觉得你吹长号时应该用不同的把位。结果他说，哦，我从头到尾都只按F调。
And I said, okay. The one song I learned how to play was Tequila. Doesn't go to position seven. It does. How'd you get there? I just would fling it out, but for a trombone player, that's a really fun song because you have the big slide. So yes, I played the trombone for a few months, and then I switched to being the school mascot.
然后我说，好吧。我学会吹的那首歌是《龙舌兰》（Tequila）。不需要用到第七把位。其实需要的。你是怎么做到的？我就是会把它甩出去，但对于长号手来说，那真是一首很好玩的歌，因为你有那个长长的滑管。所以没错，我吹了几个月长号，然后我就转行当学校吉祥物了。
That's better for you. So do you think you would buy Andy's trombone? I think I would, and I think I also have my eye on that decorative sailboat. Is the trombone a dirty joke in the American Pie movies? I think it's a dirty trombone. Oh, no. It's a rusty trombone. Oh, a rusty trombone is a sexy move.
这对你来说更好。那你觉得你会买安迪的长号吗？我想我会的，而且我觉得我也看中了那个装饰用的帆布船。长号在《美国派》电影里是不是一个带颜色的笑话？我觉得这是一个带颜色的长号。哦，不。这是一个生锈的长号。哦，生锈的长号是一个性感的动作。
More filthy than sexy. Oh. You want to cap this one off right here. Okay, Sam. Thank you. What is it? Picture the ways that you could use somebody's body like a trombone. The potential combinations.
与其说是性感，不如说是下流。哦。你真想把这个话题就在这里收尾。好吧，萨姆。谢谢你。那是什么？想象一下你可以把某人的身体当作长号来用的各种方法。那些可能的组合。
I can't figure that out, Sam. I think I am getting there. Okay. When you act it out. So I am behind a man. Okay. Imagine you're behind him. Okay.
我琢磨不透这个，萨姆。我觉得我快懂了。好吧。当你把它表演出来的时候。所以我在一个男人的后面。好吧。想象你跟在他的后面。好吧。
And then what part of their body could you kind of stroke like a trombone while you're blowing into another part of their body? Wait a second. Wait a second. Does this save them from drowning? It doesn't. It does not. Is this the kit, remember?
然后你可以用他们身体的哪个部位像长号一样去抚摸，同时对着他们身体的另一个部位吹气？等一下。等一下。这能救他们的命免于溺水吗？不能。并不能。这是那个小品里的吗，还记得吗？
Yeah. The thing with the fee-hee-hee-hee. Yeah. Is that the same part of the body? Yeah. Yes. It is the same part of the body. It's blowing in that same area.
对。那个发出“费——嘿——嘿——嘿”声音的。对。是身体的同一个部位吗？对。是的。就是身体的同一个部位。就是对着那个区域吹气。
Can I ask you both, on our potentially last year here, what song are you playing? On the trombone? During this rusty trombone. I'm playing Tequila. Well, that's a good yank. That's what I'm playing. I'm playing Imperial March. Excellent choice.
我可以问你们两个，在我们可能是在这里的最后一年里，你们在吹什么歌？在长号上？在这个生锈的长号期间。我在吹《龙舌兰》。嗯，那真是一次用力的猛拉。这就是我在吹的。我在吹《帝国进行曲》。绝佳的选择。
Thank you. What is Imperial March? Come on. Is that like when world leaders come in? No. One of them. What? I know this song.
谢谢。什么是《帝国进行曲》？拜托。那是世界领导人登场时放的音乐吗？不是。其中一个。什么？我知道这首歌。
I know this song. Dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun. Dun, dun, dun, dun, dun. Dun, dun, dun, dun. Why? What is that? Who could that be? Who could that be?
我知道这首歌。咚，咚，咚，咚，咚，咚。咚，咚，咚，咚，咚。咚，咚，咚，咚。为什么？那是什么？那会是谁？那会是谁？
It's Darth Vader. Oh, yes, of course. Yes, of course. Yes. That's my sexy yank. It's amazing. It's sensual. Mm-hmm.
那是达斯·维达。哦，对，当然。是的，当然。是的。那是我的性感猛拉。太棒了。很色情。嗯哼。
Very gentle touch. Yeah. It's sensual. It's sensual. Very gentle touch. Yes. They're going to love it, Ann. Should I include this part?
非常温柔的触碰。对。很色情。很色情。非常温柔的触碰。是的。安，他们一定会喜欢的。我应该把这段剪进去吗？
Yes. Oh, my gosh. I'm going to get the E. All right. Okay. Collecting myself. Did you say there was another table we haven't seen, Angela? Yes.
要的。哦，天哪。我要拿E。好了。好吧。平复一下心情。安吉拉，你刚才说还有一张我们没见过的桌子吗？是的。
There is another table full of ****. Okay. Yes. There is another table we haven't seen. Mm-hmm. It is Angela Martin's table. She has a bunch of cat tchotchkes. Every kind of cat figurine you could ever want.
还有一张摆满了****的桌子。好吧。是的。还有一张我们没见过的桌子。嗯哼。那是安吉拉·马丁的桌子。她有一堆猫的小摆设。你能想到的各种猫咪雕像应有尽有。
Her pricing is a bit much. Explain. Her cat figurines are priced at $30 and $29. How much did she pay for them? I don't know, but these are really high prices. Also on Erin's table, in addition to her spice rack, you can see she has a miniature doll beautician chair. Mm-hmm.
她的定价有点离谱。解释一下。她的猫咪雕像标价30美元和29美元。她进货花了多少钱？我不知道，但这些价格真的太高了。另外在艾琳的桌子上，除了她的香料架，你可以看到她还有一个微型娃娃美发师椅子。嗯哼。
Those are some other items you might have missed. Well, Holly is in the break room and Michael's going to go in. She wants to talk to him about going home to Colorado to be with her dad. Yeah. And she says, but Michael, based on our conversation earlier, I want you to come with me. And then she starts to propose to Michael.
这些是你可能错过的一些其他物品。好了，霍莉在休息室里，迈克尔要进去了。她想跟他谈谈回科罗拉多去陪她爸爸的事。对。她说，但是迈克尔，根据我们先前的谈话，我希望你跟我一起去。然后她开始向迈克尔求婚。
And he's like, no, no, no, no, no. Mm-hmm. This takes us to a talking head where he's like, I am not going to be proposed to in the break room. That is not going to be our story. Uh-uh. I should have burned this place down when I had the chance. I loved that line.
而他的反应是，不，不，不，不，不。嗯哼。这就切换到了他的独白镜头，他说，我才不在休息室里接受求婚。那绝不会成为我们的故事。休想。我真该当年有机会的时候把这地方烧了。我太喜欢这句台词了。
What is he referring to? I think when he was putting gasoline all around it. Down in the garage sale, you know, these guys have been playing this Dallas game. They've just been making up the rules because there's no instructions. Kevin's getting so annoyed. He says he's never going to play games with them again.
他在指什么？我想是他到处泼汽油的那次。在旧货售卖区，你知道的，这些人一直在玩那个达拉斯游戏。他们一直在自己编造规则，因为根本没有说明书。凯文气坏了。他说他再也不跟他们一起玩游戏了。
And it turns out all the cash is missing now. Mm-hmm. Where did it go? Kevin. Kevin stole it. And he says, and that is Dallas. And he should know because he's been on Dallas. He has.
结果证明，现在所有的现金都不见了。嗯哼。钱去哪儿了？凯文。凯文偷的。他说，这就是达拉斯。他当然知道了，因为他上过《达拉斯》。他确实上过。
He's also been on Hawaii. Yes. Well, Dwight has come a long way from starting off with attack. He's managed to trade all the way for Stanley's telescope. And he's going to walk up to Jim's table. But he's kind of bragging. Mm-hmm. And oh my gosh, the legumes are back.
他还上过《夏威夷》。是的。好吧，德怀特从最初用图钉起家，已经取得了长足的进步。他一路通过交换得到了斯坦利的望远镜。他要走向吉姆的桌子。但他有点在吹牛。嗯哼。哦，天哪，那些豆子又回来了。
How? How did they come back from being stomped on the ground and wadded up? Well, he can't take it. He's going to trade for the beans. He knows better. But he does it. And this kind of ends our garage sale.
怎么会？它们怎么在被踩在地上又揉成一团之后还能回来？好吧，他受不了了。他要拿望远镜去换那些豆子。他明明知道不该这么做。但他还是换了。这也算为我们的旧货售卖画上了句号。
Did you notice? Mm-hmm. This is kind of it. We had a fan question from Maria F. in Austin, Texas. What's the best thing you guys have ever gotten at a garage sale? We've sort of talked about what we would take from this garage sale, Angela. But do you have an amazing garage sale find? I do.
你们注意到了吗？嗯哼。差不多就是这样。我们收到了来自德克萨斯州奥斯汀的玛丽亚·F的粉丝提问。你们在旧货售卖上买过最棒的东西是什么？我们刚才大概聊了聊我们会从这个旧货售卖会上拿走什么，安吉拉。但你有没有过什么惊艳的旧货淘宝经历？我有。
And I love it. Share. I have a, this sounds like my character. I have a tuxedo cat cookie jar. That you got at a garage sale? Yes. What was this garage sale? It was somewhere in Texas.
而且我超爱它。分享一下。我有一个，这听起来太像我的人设了。我有一个燕尾服猫饼干罐。你在旧货售卖会上买的？是的。这是个什么样的旧货售卖？是在得克萨斯州的某个地方。
So here's the thing you need to know about my mom. You know how, like, people have a bumper sticker that says, we'll break for sunsets. My moms would say, we'll break for a yard sale. Mm-hmm. My whole life, we had to pull over, go into someone's yard, our garage, our estate sale. We hit every one.
所以关于我妈妈，你得知道这一点。你知道有些人车屁股后面贴着个贴纸，上面写着“我们为日落而停车”吗。我妈妈会说，“我们为旧货售卖停车”。嗯哼。我的一生中，我们不得不经常把车停在路边，去别人的院子里、车库里或遗产拍卖会。我们每一个都不放过。
It would become like a thing. If my dad drove, he'd be like, now, Barty, I don't only stop at one yard sale on this road trip. And she would be like, but Bill, you don't know what's there. So I just grew up loving them. I don't know exactly where we were, some back road in Texas, driving from my parents' house to our family reunion. But I found a tuxedo cat cookie jar.
这甚至成了一种标志。如果我爸爸开车，他就会说，好了，巴蒂，我可不在这次公路旅行的这条路上只停一个旧货摊。而她就会说，但是，比尔，你根本不知道里面有什么。所以我从小就对它们充满热爱。我不记得具体是在哪里了，是得克萨斯州的一条乡间小路，当时正从我父母家开车去我们的家庭聚会。但我找到了一个燕尾服猫饼干罐。
It has a little chip on the ear, but who cares? My mom is the same way, Angela, my whole life. Same thing. And when I got my very first department, my sophomore year in college, you know, I had to get stuff for the kitchen. Oh, yard sales are so great for that. My mom took me to a garage sale. And I got this amazing set of stainless steel cookware
它的耳朵上有一个小缺口，但谁在乎呢？我妈妈也是这样，安吉拉，我一辈子都这样。完全一样。当我有了自己的第一套公寓，也就是我上大学二年级的时候，你知道的，我得为厨房置办东西。哦，旧货售卖对那种事来说太棒了。我妈妈带我去了一个旧货售卖会。我买了一套超级棒的不锈钢炊具，
that I still have today. Yeah. That's how great this cookware was. I still have it. I got these really cool old like vintage glasses, like the big thick ones. Yeah, yeah. And they're sort of an amber color.
我到现在还留着呢。对。这套炊具就是这么棒。我到现在还留着。我还买了一些非常酷的复古老式玻璃杯，那种又大又厚的。对，对。而且它们带点琥珀色。
Still have them. Now, Jenna, I have some fun garage sale stats. Oh, according to the internet, each year it says that Americans host an estimated 6.5 to 9 million garage sales. Oh my gosh. That's according to the New York Times. And if you put some thought and planning into your garage sale, you can make between $500 and $1,000.
现在还留着。好了，珍娜，我有一些有趣的旧货售卖统计数据。哦，根据互联网的说法，据估计，美国人每年举办650万到900万场旧货售卖。哦，天哪。这是根据《纽约时报》的数据。如果你对旧货售卖花点心思和做些规划，你可以赚到500到1000美元。
Wow. Mm-hmm. My friends, Michael and Tobias do a big yard sale every year. And they go in with a few friends and they always make great money. That brings me to this. What do you think does the best at a garage sale? Books. Clothing.
哇。嗯哼。我的朋友迈克尔和托比每年都会办一场大型的旧货售卖。他们和几个朋友一起合伙，每次都能赚到很不错的钱。这就让我想到了这个。你觉得在旧货售卖上什么最卖座？书籍。服装。
Clothing, especially children's clothes. Mm-hmm. Vintage dishes and glassware. Yes. Yes. Power tools and garden tools were one of the number one things on every list I could find. Hmm.
服装，尤其是童装。嗯哼。复古盘子和玻璃器皿。是的。是的。电动工具和园艺工具是我能找到的每一个清单上的头号畅销品之一。嗯。
I know. Sports equipment, bicycles, electronics, household items and furniture. Just for fun because I love to find out what things are called in other countries. In the UK, a garage sale could be called a car boot sale or a boot fair or a jumble sale. I was talking to my friend Michael who's from Australia and he said they call it a rummage sale or a trash or treasure.
我知道。体育用品、自行车、电子产品、家居用品和家具。纯粹为了好玩，因为我喜欢了解事物在其他国家叫什么。在英国，旧货售卖可以被称为“汽车后备箱售卖”（car boot sale）、“后备箱集市”（boot fair）或“杂货售卖”（jumble sale）。我曾和我来自澳大利亚的朋友迈克尔聊过，他说他们管这叫“搜寻售卖”（rummage sale）或者“垃圾或宝贝”（trash or treasure）。
Oh. And according to the internet, the biggest yard sale in the world happens in the United States. It's called the world's longest yard sale. It's 127 yards. It covers 690 miles from Addison, Michigan to Gaston, Alabama, and it hosts vendors all along the way. This year is going to be between August 3rd and 6th.
哦。根据互联网的说法，世界上最大的旧货售卖发生在美利坚合众国。它被称为“世界最长旧货售卖”。它有127码长。横跨从密歇根州艾迪生到阿拉巴马州加斯顿的690英里，沿途接待着各路摊贩。今年的举办时间在8月3日至6日之间。
I mean, we're going to that rate. That's a long road trip. 690 miles of yard sales. They have a whole website where you can find out everything about it. I'll put it in our stories. And if you have a garage sale in your area, will you let me know what it's called? I find it so fascinating.
我的意思是，按那个节奏我们得去看看。那可是一次漫长的公路旅行。690英里的旧货售卖。他们甚至还有一个完整的网站，你可以在上面查到关于它的一切。我会把它发到我们的动态里。如果你所在的地区也有旧货售卖，你能告诉我它叫什么名字吗？我觉得这太迷人了。
Well, I love that, Angela. Should we get into the proposal? Mm-hmm. It's so wonderful. It's so sweet. Michael comes down to the warehouse. Holly is packing up the stuff. They made $13.
嗯，我太喜欢这个了，安吉拉。我们该进入求婚环节了吗？嗯哼。太美妙了。太温馨了。迈克尔来到仓库。霍莉正在打包东西。他们赚了13美元。
She also apologizes for earlier. She's like, you know what, Michael? You're my life now. I'm not going to go to Colorado. And he kind of stops her and he says, you know what? Will you take a walk with me? Yeah, the first stop on their walk is the lobby. Michael explains that this is where Toby announced that he was going to Costa Rica
她还为之前的事道歉。她说，你知道吗，迈克尔？你现在就是我的全部生活。我不去科罗拉多勒。然后他拦住她，说道，你知道吗？你愿意陪我散个步吗？对，他们散步的第一站是大厅。迈克尔解释说，这里就是托比宣布他要去哥斯达黎加的地方，那是迈克尔一生中最快乐的一天，直到他遇到了霍莉。
and it was the happiest day of Michael's life until he met Holly. Now, Angela, we had a fan catch. OK. From JCF in Kansas City, Kansas, who said, I have been waiting this whole podcast to point out this continuity catch. What? When Toby announced the news that he was going to Costa Rica, Michael was in New York with Ryan and Dwight.
现在，安吉拉，我们有一个粉丝捕捉到的穿帮。好的。来自堪萨斯州堪萨斯城的JCF说，我等这一整期播客就是为了指出这个连续性穿帮。什么？当托比宣布他要去哥斯达黎加的消息时，迈克尔正和瑞安以及德怀特在纽约。
How could he know that this is where Toby announced he was leaving? It's true. That is true. Michael wasn't there for the announcement. Oh, wow. That's a great catch. I know. Well done.
他怎么可能知道这里就是托比宣布他要离开的地方？确实。那是真的。迈克尔当时不在场宣布现场。哦，天哪。真是个精彩的捕捉。我知道。干得好。
He is then going to lead Holly to the stairwell where they first kissed and first made love. Now they're up in the bullpen. They're outside of Michael's office because that is where he first saw her through the blinds. It's also where he called her on the phone to tell her that he had herpes and was still in love with her. And here's where we find out the news that it was not herpes. It was just an ingrown hair.
然后他将带着霍莉去到他们第一次接吻和第一次发生关系的楼梯间。现在他们来到了办公区。他们在迈克尔办公室的百叶窗外面，因为那是他第一次透过百叶窗看到她的地方。这也是他打电话给她告诉她自己得了疱疹但依然爱着她的地方。而在这里我们得知了一个消息，那根本不是疱疹。那只是一根倒长进去的毛发。
The conference room is where they led their first meeting together. And this leads them to the water cooler. Nothing happened there. But Michael shares with Holly that he would pretend to get a cup of water so he could stare at her through the window. And then he acts out getting his cup of water and looking at her through the blinds. Here's where it gets good. Jenna, I went to the shooting draft because I wanted to see how the next part of the scene was set up.
会议室是他们第一次一起开会的地方。这把他们带到了饮水机旁。那里什么也没发生。但迈克尔告诉霍莉，他会假装去拿杯水，这样他就可以通过窗户凝视她。然后他表演了自己去拿水杯并通过百叶窗看着她。精彩的来了。珍娜，我查阅了拍摄剧本，因为我想看看这一场景的下一部分是如何设定的。
It says, interior kitchen. Michael and Holly enter. The entire office is in there lining both sides of the kitchen, creating a pathway. The blinds are shut on the far door and they each hold a lit candle. Holly says, hi guys. Michael says, this is where our love face its toughest test. After this, smooth sailing for the rest of our lives. And then it says, Holly is nervous with anticipation.
上面写着，内景，厨房。迈克尔和霍莉进入。整个办公室的人都在里面，排在厨房的两侧，形成了一条通道。远处门上的百叶窗是关着的，他们每个人手里都拿着一支点燃的蜡烛。霍莉说，嗨，伙计们。迈克尔说，这是我们的爱情面临最严峻考验的地方。在此之后，我们余生将一帆风顺。然后上面写着，霍莉满怀期待地感到紧张。
Michael, confident and cool, takes her arm and walks her through the room. And then one by one, different people ask Holly if she will marry them. And she has to say no to each person. This was my line in the episode. Yes, look, you marry me. And I loved this. I don't know if you noticed in Amy Ryan's performance, but from the minute that door opens and she sees all of us holding the candles, she immediately gets tears in her eyes and a lump in her throat.
自信而冷静的迈克尔挽起她的手臂，带她穿过房间。然后，大家一个接一个地问霍莉是否愿意嫁给他们。而她必须对每个人说不。这是我在这一集里的台词。是的，看，你嫁给我吧。我很喜欢这个。我不知道你有没有注意到艾米·瑞安的表演，但从那扇门打开、她看到我们所有人拿着蜡烛的那一刻起，她眼里立刻涌出了泪水，喉咙也哽咽了。
Like you can just hear it and you can see this flush on her face. It's just beautiful. Every single minute of the scene, Amy is like a masterclass in acting, just watching her. So after they get through this row of people, they get back into the annex, which is lit with more candles than I've ever seen, ever. Clearly Michael had help because how do you set up this many candles? It's like in a reality TV show when the bachelor or whatever takes them back to the mansion and there's like 400 candles. I'm always like, okay, can we call BS on how many candles?
就像你能听到一样，你能看到她脸上泛起的红晕。真是太美了。这一场景的每一分钟，艾米就像在上演技大师课，看着她。所以当他们穿过这排人后，他们回到了附楼，这里点着比我见过的任何时候都多的蜡烛。显然迈克尔得到了帮助，因为你怎么能布置这么多蜡烛？这就像真人秀节目里，单身汉或什么人带他们回豪宅，里面有400支蜡烛一样。我总是想，好吧，我们能对这么多蜡烛表示质疑吗？
Well, Michael and Holly both get on their knees. And he's about to say this is where we fixed that broken chair. But then the sprinklers go off and douse them with water. But Michael still pulls out the ring. He proposes in his Yoda voice and Holly accepts in her Yoda voice. And we all burst through into the annex. We're all soaking wet and this is the line that when I saw it in our rewatch made me sob. And I don't even know if I can say it now because I remember how it felt when we did the scene.
好吧，迈克尔和霍莉都单膝跪下了。他正要说这就是我们修好那把坏椅子的地方。但随后洒水器启动了，用水浇透了他们。但迈克尔还是掏出了戒指。他用尤达的声音求婚，霍莉也用尤达的声音接受了。我们所有人都冲进了附楼。我们都湿透了，这就是当我们在重看时看到这一幕让我大哭的台词。我甚至不知道现在能不能说出来，因为我记得我们拍摄这一场景时的感觉。
He says, you know, she said yes. And then he says, Michael says, and I'm leaving. Yeah. And it was the first time Steve had really said it out loud to us. We all knew. We knew he was leaving. We knew it was coming. But when he said it in the episode, I remember when they cut to the looks on our faces,
他说，你知道，她答应了。然后他说，迈克尔说，我要离开这里了。是的。这是史蒂夫第一次真正对我们大声说出来。我们都知道。我们知道他要走了。我们知道这一天要来。但当他在这一集里说出来时，我记得当镜头切到我们脸上的表情时，
that was because we were hearing Steve Carell, our friend, say, I'm leaving to us. It was so real. Really for the first time. Yeah. It was so real. Yeah. And I just like, I experienced that emotion all over again in this rewatch. I remember so clearly that moment because we were all so happy when she said yes.
那是因为我们听到史蒂夫·卡瑞尔，我们的朋友，对我们说，我要离开了。太真实了。真的是第一次。是的。太真实了。是的。我只是，我在这次重温中重新体验了那种情绪。我清楚地记得那一刻，因为当她答应时，我们所有人都太高兴了。
We were like, we were as fans of our own show. We were so happy that Holly and Michael found each other and the water was so cold and we were all really reacting to that. We all got soaking wet. So there was this huge sort of well of emotion of happiness and, oh my God, it's so cold. And then when Steve, as Michael said, I'm leaving, it was like the air sucked out of the room. It was just so many things happening at once.
我们就像，我们作为自己节目的粉丝。我们为霍莉和迈克尔找到彼此感到由衷的高兴，而且水太冷了，我们所有人对此都做出了真实的反应。我们全都湿透了。因此，有一种巨大的幸福感和“噢天哪，太冷了”的情绪涌上心头。然后当史蒂夫饰演的迈克尔说“我要走了”时，感觉房间里的空气都被抽干了。真的是有太多事情同时发生了。
And it was so powerful as just Steve's friend and co-worker. You can imagine we got a fan mail flurry about this scene. Kyle S. in Victoria, British Columbia said, I have so many questions about the technical side of this proposal scene. Were all of the candles really burning in Michael's proposal or were any of them CGI? What was the safety meeting like for shooting that scene? And what went into preparing the set of the annex for being completely destroyed by water so that it could either be reset for another take or another episode?
作为史蒂夫的朋友和同事，这种感觉太有冲击力了。你可以想象，我们收到了大量关于这个场景的粉丝来信。来自不列颠哥伦比亚省维多利亚市的凯尔·S说，关于这个求婚场景的技术层面，我有很多问题。迈克尔求婚时所有的蜡烛真的都在燃烧吗，还是其中有一些是CGI特效？拍摄这个场景的安全会议是怎样的？为了让附楼布景被水完全破坏，以便它可以为另一次拍摄或另一集重新设置，都做了哪些准备工作？
Well, we got all the details from Randy. We sure did. First of all, all of the candles were very real. I like to remember Kelly saying something like this. Safety meeting. We have 372 lit candles. That's crazy. Randy mentioned, though, that lighting all the candles, like you said, Angela, Michael
好吧，我们从兰迪那里得到了所有的细节。我们确实得到了。首先，所有的蜡烛都是绝对真实的。我喜欢记得凯莉说过这样的话。安全会议。我们有372支点燃的蜡烛。这太疯狂了。不过兰迪提到，点燃所有的蜡烛，就像你说的，安吉拉，迈克尔
must have had help. Well, this was not the job of one person. Here's how we did it. Randy said that it took a special effects team of three people plus our set dressing crew of four people, plus all of our prop and art department crew consisting of eight people. So what is that? Eight plus four plus three, 15 people to make this moment happen. Yes.
一定得到了帮助。好吧，这不是一个人的工作。我们是这样做的。兰迪说，这需要一个由3人组成的特效团队加上由4人组成的布景装饰团队，再加上由8人组成的道具和艺术部门团队。那是多少？8加4加3，15个人来促成这一时刻。是的。
Every person got a fireplace lighter and Kelly Cantley after her safety announcement would say go and those people could light all those candles in just a few minutes, you know, because they had to do it right before action because we couldn't leave those candles burning. Randy said there was actually a significant amount of heat and fumes caused by these candles. We had actual fire alarms that they would trigger if we let them burning too long. Randy said that Michael Gallenberg, who was our production designer, and Tim James, our construction coordinator, actually installed special exhaust fans and air scrubbers above the annex to cycle the air, but we couldn't run them while we were filming.
每个人都拿到了一把壁炉打火机，凯莉·坎特利在发布安全公告后会说“开始”，这些人可以在短短几分钟内点燃所有这些蜡烛，你知道的，因为他们必须在“开始”拍摄前立刻这样做，因为我们不能让那些蜡烛一直燃着。兰迪说，这些蜡烛实际上产生了大量的热量和烟雾。如果我们让它们燃烧太久，它们真的会触发火灾报警器。兰迪说，我们的制作设计师迈克尔·盖伦伯格和我们的施工协调员蒂姆·詹姆斯实际上在附楼上方安装了特殊的排气扇和空气洗涤器来循环空气，但在我们拍摄时我们不能运行它们。
So that's why we had to light the candles and start shooting really quickly. And then in terms of the sprinklers, I did not realize how much work went into this. When we got these details from Randy, I was, wow. I mean, they had to soak all of the annex plus the kitchen. It was crazy. Here's what they had to do. The previous weekend, Tim James's crew took all of the furniture and set dressing out of the kitchen and annex.
所以这就是为什么我们必须点燃蜡烛并非常迅速地开始拍摄。然后说到洒水器，我之前没有意识到这需要做这么多工作。当我们从兰迪那里得到这些细节时，我简直惊呆了。我的意思是，他们不得不把整个附楼加上厨房都弄湿。这太疯狂了。他们必须这样做：上周末，蒂姆·詹姆斯的团队把厨房和附楼的所有家具和布景装饰都搬出去了。
They removed the walls and the carpet down to the bare stage floor. Then they added a waterproofing floor liner to go underneath and then rebuilt the entire set to sit inside of a pan, which is like a low bathtub thing that would collect all the water. So it wouldn't ruin our actual stage floor or any of the adjacent sets because you don't want to get that water stuck in there and get mold and stuff. Then all of the lighting and electrical cables had to be grounded, waterproofed, and they had to have a safety inspection from a rep at Universal Studios.
他们拆除了墙壁和地毯，只剩下裸露的舞台地板。然后他们添加了一个防水地板衬垫铺在下面，接着重新搭建了整个布景，使其坐落在一个盘子里，这就像一个低矮的浴缸似的东西，可以收集所有的水。这样它就不会毁坏我们真正的舞台地板或任何相邻的布景，因为你不想让水滞留在那里面并滋生霉菌之类的东西。然后所有的照明和电缆都必须接地、做防水处理，并且必须通过环球影城代表的安全检查。
They had to build a huge grid of PVC pipes over the annex and kitchen with sprinklers that would believably sprinkle the water. But we also had to prime the sprinklers beforehand because where the water tank was was kind of far away from all the pipes and we needed the water to come out right on cue. So we couldn't wait for that lag time. So they would turn it on and put big buckets down to collect the little bit of sprinkle, turn it off, and then when they said action, then it would come right out. I guess the special effects team used a boiler tank so that the water would not be like totally
他们必须在附楼和厨房上方建造一个巨大的PVC管道网，配上能够逼真洒水的喷头。但我们也必须事先对喷头进行预灌水，因为水箱所在的位置距离所有管道有点远，我们需要水能够准时喷出。所以我们不能等待那种滞后时间。因此他们会打开它并放下大桶来收集一点点洒出的水，将其关闭，然后当他们喊“开始”时，水就会立刻喷出来。我猜特效团队使用的是一个锅炉水箱，这样水就不会显得完全
freezing cold. But Randy said during our setup, the water cooled inside the pipes, so the first blast was really cold. He said as evidenced by Amy Ryan's face and reaction. I thought it was so perfect, though. I mean, that water was cold. I remember it being very cold. Plus, our soundstage was freezing.
冰冷。但兰迪说在我们的布景搭建期间，水在管道内部冷却了，所以第一道水流真的很冷。他说艾米·瑞安的脸和反应就是证明。不过我觉得这太完美了。我的意思是，那水真的很冷。我记得它非常冷。另外，我们的摄影棚冷得要命。
Yeah. So you're already cold and then it was cold water, but it made for such a cute, sweet, fun reaction. We got another fan question from Brianna L and Katie Texas who wanted to know how many times did we have to get soaking wet for this proposal scene. Randy said we shot the scene on Wednesday, February 2nd. He said we were prepared to do a massive cleanup and go again the next day and then again on Friday if we needed to.
是的。所以你本来就很冷，然后又是冷水，但这造就了一个非常可爱、甜蜜、有趣的反应。我们收到了来自得克萨斯州布里安娜·L和凯蒂的另一个粉丝问题，她们想知道为了这个求婚场景我们不得不全身湿透多少次。兰迪说我们在2月2日星期三拍摄了这一场景。他说我们准备进行大规模清理，如果需要的话，第二天再来一次，周五再来一次。
So we had three chances to get it, but there was no way to turn it over in a single day. But Randy said we got it on the first take. Yeah, that was my memory, too. I remember, though, that they did turn off the sprinklers for a second and we all put on robes and we were kind of shivering and they were watching the footage to make sure we had it. Yeah. And then they turned the sprinklers on again and they got a couple of extra reaction shots
所以我们有三次机会来完成它，但没法在单日内将其翻新。不过兰迪说我们一条就过了。是的，这也是我的记忆。不过我记得他们把洒水器关了一秒钟，我们都穿上了长袍，有点瑟瑟发抖，他们正在查看素材以确保我们拍到了。是的。然后他们再次打开洒水器，拍了几个额外的反应镜头
and then we were done. Yeah. I watched this episode with my daughter and she was like, Mom, you're so happy for Michael and Holly because I run in with everyone else cheering. And I said, yeah, I think, honestly, Isabel, even Angela Martin was happy that Michael found his person. Maybe happy that he's leaving. Maybe one of the people.
然后我们就完成了。是的。我和女儿一起看了这一集，她对我说，妈妈，你为迈克尔和霍莉感到太高兴了，因为我和其他人一起跑进去欢呼。我说，是的，我觉得，老实说，安吉拉·马丁也为迈克尔找到了他的人生伴侣而高兴。也许是因为他要走了而高兴。也许是其中一个人。
Well, Angela, we got one more piece of fan mail about this proposal scene from Madison C. in Baltimore, Maryland, who said, I don't have a question, but I wanted to share a story related to this episode. My husband proposed to me on December 31st, 2018, and he recreated the Holly and Michael proposal from this episode. He had our friends line up holding candles and recite the lines that the characters said in the episode. I was so surprised and it was such a cool proposal since I'm such a huge fan.
好吧，安吉拉，我们收到了来自马里兰州巴尔的摩市的麦迪逊·C发来的关于这个求婚场景的又一封粉丝来信，她写道，我没有问题，但我想分享一个与这一集相关的故事。我丈夫在2018年12月31日向我求婚，他重现了这一集中霍莉和迈克尔的求婚。他让我们的朋友排成一行拿着蜡烛，背诵剧中角色所说台词。我太惊讶了，因为我是个超级粉丝，所以这真是一个非常酷的求婚。
Love you ladies. So cute. Yeah, I love that. So creative. Thanks for sharing. I love that. Well, this episode is going to end with more of Jim's prank. Dwight is watering five big planters of the legumes he's planted them.
爱你们，女士们。太可爱了。是的，我很喜欢这个。太有创意了。谢谢分享。我很喜欢。好吧，这一集将以吉姆的更多恶作剧结束。德怀特正在给他种植的五大盆豆科植物浇水。
And when he steps away, Jim sneaks around the corner with almost full grown potted plants. Yes. As if after Dwight watered them, they immediately grew. Well, they're magical. I know. Of course. We did have a fan question from Little K. in Israel. Dwight has a huge farm.
当他走开时，吉姆拿着几乎长成的盆栽植物鬼鬼祟祟地走到拐角处。是的。就像德怀特浇水后它们立刻长大了一样。好吧，它们是神奇的。我知道。当然。我们确实收到了来自以色列的小K的粉丝问题。德怀特有一个巨大的农场。
Why would he plant the seeds in pots in the Dunder Mifflin parking lot? This is a good point. This is a fair question. This is a fair question. I had not thought of that. You know what? I thought when I saw this because I love plants. I've been planting quite a bit of new plants in my backyard.
他为什么要邓德米夫林停车场的花盆里种种子？这是个好观点。这是一个合理的问题。这是一个合理的问题。我之前没有想到这一点。你知道吗？当我看到这个时我想到了，因为我喜欢植物。我一直在我的后院种植相当多的新植物。
I want to know what Jim's prank budget is. And does Pam know about this prank budget? Because those mature plants are not cheap. You're so right. I'm just saying. How much money does he spend on pranking Dwight each year? Yeah. Well, listen, guys.
我想知道吉姆的恶作剧预算是多少。帕姆知道这个恶作剧预算吗？因为那些成熟的植物可不便宜。你说得太对了。我只是说说而已。他每年花多少钱在捉弄德怀特上？是的。好吧，听着，伙计们。
That's garage sale. Thank you so much for listening and sending in your questions and comments. Thank you always to Randy Cordray for great behind the scenes information. And I guess we're going to go get our boxes and we're going to move somewhere. We don't know where. We really don't know. That's what's crazy is we're recording an episode next week. And we're not sure where we're recording it.
那是车库大卖场。非常感谢你们的收听并发送你们的问题和评论。一如既往地感谢兰迪·科德雷提供精彩的幕后信息。我想我们要去拿我们的箱子，我们要搬到某个地方去。我们不知道去哪儿。我们真的不知道。最疯狂的是我们下周要录制一集。我们不确定我们在哪里录制它。
We'll let you know next week where we landed. All right, you guys have a great one. We love you. See you then. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins.
我们下周会让你知道我们在哪里落脚。好了，你们过得愉快。我们爱你们。回头见。感谢收听办公室女士。《办公室女士》由Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金斯利制作。我们的节目由科迪·费舍尔执行制片。我们的制作人是卡西·杰金斯。
Our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer. And our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbicoe. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one month trial of Stitcher Premium, use code, OFFICE. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗。我们的副制作人是艾斯利·布比科。我们的主题曲是克里·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。要收听无广告版本的《办公室女士》，请访问StitcherPremium.com。要获得Stitcher Premium的一个月免费试用，请使用代码：OFFICE。这一集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。